welcome to an ALT shift X live stream to
discuss House of the Dragon episode 9
we're going to talk all about the
episode we're going to answer your
questions we are not going to spoil
future episodes and there's going to be
a shorter explained video coming later
in the week
folks this episode was balls to the wall
Bonkers this episode was wild this
episode did a lot of crazy stuff that is
not in the books they really weren't
off the script on this one and
I I think I liked it it was crazy they
had like this whole
game this whole like this this whole
like thriller movie of trying to grab
King aegon and get control of the king
the the most important piece in the
chess game was was aegon and aegon had
no interest in being King he was
literally running this this young man
was sprinting away from the throne and
they had to drag him to it kicking and
screaming
and and yet I thought it was so
beautiful that you know aegon on the way
to his coronation
he had no interest in the politics but
he was just saying man I really wish one
of my parents loved me I really wish
someone loved me and then at his
coronation when he saw the thousands of
people shouting his name
he bathed in the Adoration because in
the first time in his life he he
actually felt loved and I think this is
such a great Arc for aegon as a villain
because it shows how
it shows how he becomes invested in
being King it's not for any of the
politics it's just because of his deep
need to be loved and we also learned
that he's a Monster who like
participates in child pit fights but
we'll get to that we'll get to that
we also had this bananas moment with
rainey's Targaryen bursting up through
the floor of the Dragon pit on her
Dragon meles during aegon's coronation
facing the greens faction looking as
though for a moment she was about to
burn and and kill all of the greens but
chose not to she took the moral High
ground and she left
which is which which was not in the
books it's something that probably would
have made the history books uh you know
the fact that there was a there was a
dragon at the coronation
um so this is a bit of a deviation from
the books but I thought that was
interesting it's really rainy sending a
message to Allison saying like hey we
need to choose peace like we as women
are not going to allow the men to drag
us into bloody war we need to take the
moral High ground and we need to prevent
War
because that's sort of what happened in
that conversation between rhaenys and
Allison where rainey's told Alison hey
like are you going to let your father
start a war over this are you going to
get rhaenyra and her children murdered
or are you going to take control of the
situation and do this in a more moral
respectable way I thought it was such a
cool Choice how Alison
Alison wants aegon to be king so she
comes to small Council saying yeah
aegon's going to be king but she's
horrified to see
that everyone else at the small Council
Otto and the iron rod and Thailand they
have been plotting to do this coup for
years without telling her and while
Alison has like this deep emotional
reason to support aegon that she wants
to honor the memory of her husband King
viserys
the the men were going to do it anyway
they don't give a [ __ ] about her deep
emotional reason for supporting aegon
they're doing it for for their own
political Ambitions so Allison and Otto
both have the same goal of wanting to
put aegon on the throne but they have
completely different motivations and
they have a different moral approach
because Allison does not want to kill
Rainier and her family But Otto
considers that a necessity
and as evil as it is that Otto is saying
we should murder raniera and her
children he might be right he might be
right you know a few Must Die for the
good of the realm
incidentally how many people did rhaenys
and melis kill when she burst up through
the dragon pit
like rainy like rainies may be taking
the moral High Ground here but she just
killed like I mean probably like
hundreds of these random innocent common
people when she burst up through the
floor didn't you
it's funny how like even the more moral
characters like rhaenys are still
slaughtering random peasants for no
reason all day and all night
um so yeah that was wild mazaria is like
a social activist I was not expecting
that
um mazaria took control of aegon and
like hid him in the church uh and then
mazario was saying to Otto like hey
maybe we should not allow child uh slave
pit fights in this city like mazaria I
think is someone who has suffered
slavery and has suffered exploitation
and she wants to protect others which
which is not something that's in the
books but you know it makes sense I
suppose the mazaria you know wants to
protect others from the thing that
happened to her
um but yeah that was a really
interesting change and I thought it was
hilarious that aegon was found literally
locked into like the central plinth in
the sept in the city which is absurd but
I I kind of love it the irony of this
like drunk wasted prince in this holy
place
uh and uh B's in the chat bees in the
chat because Lord Lyman beesbury is dead
uh Lord Layman was uh kind of losing his
marbles kind of daughtery didn't really
seem in control of what was going on
um but it was Lord Layman beesberry he
alone well not he alone but it was it
was Lyman beesbury who stood up and said
hey maybe we should not steal the throne
from rhaenyra because bazarus always
said that you know rhaenyra was was who
he wanted on the throne
and then Kristen killed Lyman beesberry
sort of impaled him on his Council ball
can you impale someone on a ball because
Kristen just did
um so that that was dark in in the books
mushroom claims that Kristen threw
beesberry out a window
uh and I think it's Eustis who says that
he just slits his throat but here in Hot
D he uh he balls him right in the Noggin
so yeah bees in the chat and also like
you know against like like while mazaria
was taking the king and doing her whole
um cat and mouse game
uh Lionel strong approached Allison and
was informing Alison about like the Spy
Network that mazaria has and we come to
the Charming Revelation that uh Lara
strong is a foot fetishist and and he's
feeding elephant information in return
for some glimpses of her queenly feat
for him to masturbate to
which which you'll be shocked to hear is
not in the books
uh and you know it kind of makes sense
um in a funny way like Laris has a
deformed club foot and so he fetishizes
beautiful female feet and I guess I
guess this is what he's getting out of
it like people were speculating that oh
Laris is is trying to start War for his
political advancement and he's secretly
a green Seer and he's secretly playing
both sides maybe he just likes fate
or maybe D all of the above but um yeah
facing the chat folks feet in the chat
okay we will uh answer your questions
uh let's see what you guys are talking
about
um this was a crazy episode let's talk
about it thank you for the Super Chat
from feebot who says I haven't watched
the episode yet but I'm as excited for
your live streams oh thanks feebot uh
Flawless says viserys pleading oh those
are from a week ago I'm sorry I didn't
get to those earlier uh thanks for Super
Chat from Catherine who says why does
sir crusty hole Kristen Cole get to pop
off and murder people and no one bats an
eye like no one even looked scared after
Harold backed off
uh yeah well the reason why Kristen can
justify killing Lyman is that Lyman was
a traitor and traitors must die a
traitor's death
um
and everyone knows that Kristen sort of
has Alison's support I mean this This Is
War now you know this is War people are
being murdered and if you don't side
with aegon on Team Green you die that is
the message that is being sent there it
was sort of weird the way Kristen like
like just shoved beesbury's head to the
table like I think that maybe Kristen
did not intend to kill Lyman beesberry
it was just sort of an accident that the
ball was there and it entered his his
Buzzy little brain and all these honey
leaked out
um so yeah I mean it is pretty wild I
mean Kristin Cole has a long history of
doing crazy violent stuff and getting
away with it so that so that's nothing
new but I thought that it was a really
cool addition that you know it created
this tension with Harold westling
and Harold westling left the greens and
just and and no one even tried to stop
him because I I guess he's just too
badass and too respected to be stopped
which is a whole lot like uh barrist and
selmy in season one of Game of Thrones
um when Barrison says like hey like I I
mean it's sort of a different situation
because powerstone gets
um kicked out of the King's Guard
but in season one episode eight he he he
leaves and storms out and and goes and
joins his preferred candidate Daenerys
Targaryen when Joffrey dismisses
barriston
um and he has a very sort of badass exit
so I thought it was a similar situation
with um Harold westerling in this
episode
um thank you for the Super Chat from
Arthur Who Says can you watch the show
with my grandparents to explain what's
going on
um thanks for the Super Chat from
Ishmael bit of foot fetish
representation I just wish we got some
more celtica representation uh Liam asks
about fever dream George wrote a vampire
novel Liz says switching sides to team
white worm I mean I hope that the white
worm mazaria is alive because because
Allison said okay like Laris like if uh
Missouri is running this rival spy
Network in the red keep I mean she was
saying that Missouri was working with
Otto like feeding information to Otto
but you know she clearly has her own
things going on as well and she has this
sort of social activist agenda I suppose
um but then Alison agreed for Laris to
go and kill mazaria so then later we saw
one of Larissa's fireflies burning down
a house that I suppose mazaria was in
um so mazaria might be dead now question
mark question mark I hope she's okay and
I continue to wonder what mazaria's
relationship to Daemon might be because
last time we saw mazaria and Daemon
together you know it was sort of it was
sort of weird it was sort of a bit
um it's not as friendly as it used to be
and so I wonder if they might reconnect
but you know Missouri is working with
the greens and against Laris and so
there's a very sort of complicated web
of allegiances going on here John says
that rhaenys not burning everybody was
right from a writing standpoint she's
not a ruthless kin Slayer yeah yeah I
mean it would be pretty wild for rhaenys
to just murder all the greens here but
she's trying to
she's she's trying to
prevent a massive bloody war
is what she's trying to do uh Brimstone
says melis declared war rhaenys could
have ended it with one dracarus curious
scene they wrote yeah it's a really
interesting choice with rhaenys
um I I think I see it really as a
message to Alison it's like I could have
killed you and I didn't because I
believe we can be better than this like
that's what she was telling Alison in in
the room and I thought it was so
interesting how that led to
Allison opposing Otto like for the first
time in the series we finally got to see
Alison standing up to Otto when I wasn't
saying like I realize now that you have
been manipulating me you have treated me
as a porn in a chess game all my life
and I'm not going to accept that anymore
and you know it's it's so interesting
that Alison is Being Framed as like like
Alison's main motivation here is to
prevent her father Otto from going and
killing rhaenyra like that's Alison's
main concern this episode which is so
interesting because you know she's
framed as this villain and as the leader
of the greens but she's not really the
one escalating the conflict you know
um
lucky says that rainy's not killing the
greens yeah and Shane says rainey's hit
them with the imma get my dragon I enjoy
I enjoyed how rainy's just sort of
slinked off she slunk off uh during the
dragon pit situation so that she could
burst up with her Dragon are there no
like locked doors in between the dragon
Pit and the dragons like that I wonder
if the dragon Keepers were down there I
would have liked it if like when rhaenys
went off maybe rainey's could have like
met with some of the Dragon Keepers down
there and the dragon Keepers might have
like helped rhaenys get mellies because
the dragon Keepers I think are sort of
Their Own Thing the dragon keepers are
like this weird little Valyrian speaking
Valyrian culty sort of their own group
and I would have liked to have seen the
dragon Keeper's Aid rhaenys because
rhaenys would have a relationship with
the dragon Keepers because she keeps a
dragon at the dragon pit so um so yeah I
thought that was interesting
um and seeing all of the common people
getting herded into the coated into the
dragon pit and of course you know we've
seen the dragon pit before in Game of
Thrones when it's a ruin many years
later like in season seven they have
that big meeting at the dragon pit it's
like the biggest open place in King's
Landing where you can get everyone
together so it's the logical place to do
the coronation and I like how they you
know used all of the obvious symbols of
kingly legitimacy to legitimize aegon
this is the first time that we've seen
uh the iron well the Valyrian steel and
Ruby crown of aegon the Conqueror
and aegon also uses the sword blackfyre
the Valyrian steel sword of aegon and he
has the dagger the catspaw dagger that
was aegons and he's got the name of
aegon so when you've got all of those
symbols of legitimacy then of course you
must be the real king
how could anyone think otherwise in the
books it was Kristen Cole who placed the
crown on his head and then aegon flew a
few times around the city riding his
Dragon Sunfire in the books
um but we've barely glimpsed Sunfire in
the show so far
I also enjoyed amon's role here because
aemond made it very clear a bunch of
times that aemond wants the throne for
himself he considers himself more
qualified than aegon is
and you know sort of grappling with him
and tussling and this whole sort of
sibling rivalry and amont has this whole
you know I'm more worthy of the crown
because while you were partying I
studied the blade and I studied history
and I should be the king
um
and aegon would rather like for aemond
to take the throne instead of him aegon
says like hey like I'll run away I'm not
qualified I don't want to be king let me
go but he was drag Kicking and Screaming
to the throne and so that that creates a
really interesting Dynamic with aemond
who wants the throne more than he does
and there's all the stuff with like arik
and Eric the twins the kingsguard twins
um and Eric left Team Green because he
has like more of a moral complex Compass
than his identical brother Eric and so
Eric is with the greens while Eric left
and went to join Marine era
uh there's a lot going on Alan Caswell
AC like Alan Caswell was one of those
loyal Lords to rhaenyra and like he was
the one who created her outside the red
keep last episode and looked like he was
going to be an ally for Rainier and so
he tried to sneak off and alert rainyro
to her crown being stolen but Alan
Caswell got hanged and caught and killed
so he's another casualty of this episode
uh Musa says that those balls turned out
to be a workplace Hazard I I really
enjoyed how uh they were sort of toying
with the balls you could say
um when like they turned up at the small
council meeting and Thailand like rolled
his Council ball
um and to clock in
um and Otto was sort of uh was sort of
holding his ball he was sort of
playing with his ball while he was let's
be mature guys he was playing with his
ball and then they they roll yeah here
we are he sort of rolls the ball
from Iron Rod to Thailand
it's a fun prop and I'm glad they're
having fun with it I'm still waiting for
a shot where Like A ball rolls through a
puddle of blood like I was I was
expecting when beesberry was bleeding
onto the table I I thought that they
would show like blood on the ball or
something that might have been cool
thanks for the Super Chat from Dish who
says does Alison pay Laris with special
viewings of her feet yes I think that is
what's going on I mean you know I I
think that Laris is interested in more
than just feet picks like I think that
he absolutely has like a political angle
as well like he made himself Lord you
know killing Harwin and Lionel and you
know I I think that he's in he's into it
for more than just fate but yeah that is
clearly part of the appeal for him we
always did see this sort of like creepy
staring uh attraction that Laris has for
Alison and I suppose that um
I suppose we find that it really is at
least partly a sexual thing for him I I
really got the sense that Alison is just
so icked out and so tired with all of
the horniness of all the men around her
like she is surrounded by men who are
causing problems with their with the
libido like she's got her son aegon
going around raping servants and
creating all this horrible trouble and
um you know the child fights and stuff
you know so her son's crazy horniness is
a problem he was masturbating out
windows previously
um and like viserys's attraction to
Allison in the first place is like how
they got together and Alison got dragged
into this in the first place Kristen has
this sort of
I think romantic love for Allison like
it's not a totally sexual one it's more
of an abstract nightly courtly love but
I think Kristen has his attraction to
Alison
um and there's just all this like male
sexual energy and male pride and ego
that I think is driving so much of this
conflict and I think Alison is super
icked out by it and super conscious of
it in this moment and and you know I've
said before that I think that the whole
house of the Dragon Story like it's all
about sex being made politically
significant like it is it is sex with
Stakes that is what a medieval political
drama is sex with Stakes because whoever
has sex whoever who like who hooks up
with who determines the political future
of the Kingdom because it is a monarchy
where where blood and and a throughout
and the throne is inherited and I think
that's what creates the drama in this
show
uh yeah thanks Val we've sort of talked
about Rainey so I think she's taking the
moral High Ground
um max says I think the Rainy scene is
foreshadowing common folk hating the
dragons yeah well we're not going to
spoil anything but yeah I I think that
you know the common people are maybe not
going to be huge fans of dragons given
that melis just like rampaged through
the city and probably killed a bunch of
people
um and and that it has always been one
of the themes I mean not even just with
Dragons specifically the line that Jorah
says about you know when the high Lords
play their Game of Thrones it's the
common people who suffer most and you
know I you know I really like throughout
this whole ceremony how you know there
was so much dignity and and sort of
Holiness they had the sept and the oils
and everything seemed so like official
and proper
um
from the point of view of the people
watching this ceremony but like we know
that so much dirty cheating lying [ __ ]
happens to lead up to this moment with
the people hanged and and the beesberry
killed and the prince dragged out blamed
drunk from under an altar like that's
all of the dirty political lying
underbelly that led to this like
Immaculate political ceremony and so it
gives us a wonderful view of like the
falseness of historical political
narratives you know like that's part of
the theme of the book is that the the
political the political world presents
itself as being clean and Immaculate and
divine right and Noble princes but the
reality is always so much more dirty
um so yeah I really enjoyed that that
view that we got of like the CD
underbelly of flea bottom
um and this thing with like the children
fighting each other like [ __ ] Pokemon
is uh is inspired by the description in
the books in the books it says that they
found aegon here watching children with
filed sharp teeth fighting each other
for entertainment
um It also says that a very young girl
was giving uh oral sex to aegon that's
how it's described in the books and so
uh and it and you know I I think it's
really cool how they also like subtly
told us oh and by the way aegon has
bastard children here like aegon has not
only participated in this like evil
immoral pit of iniquity aegon has
apparently hooked up with women here sex
workers slaves whatever the situation is
and aegon has had bastard children
um which also is based on the books but
like yeah there are now confirmed
bastard children of King aegon II in
flea bottom which could be politically
significant you know like any rival
claimant to the throne is is potentially
a danger so like that kid and any other
kids could be important
um one of many I'd wager says Eric or
Eric
so yeah I really enjoyed I really
enjoyed seeing all of that and there was
this girl Jane
um there was this there was this woman
who was like at the flea bottom Place
who is apparently working with mazaria
and she led
um Eric and Eric and Otto to talk to
yeah here she is this girl Jane at first
seeing this girl I thought she might be
Nettles not going to spoil anything but
that is that there is a character later
on who I thought that might be but
apparently according to the subtitles
this is a woman called Jane and I guess
she's just someone who works with um
mazaria
thanks for the Super Chat from
wealthwolf who says I came to this
series expecting maegor with tits who
would have thought that we'd see
Alison's Feats thank you wealthwolf
Sebastian says I hope the Queen's feet
become a main character
um Bonk
thank you Monk who says lamris support
lariss throwing his support behind house
togarian and Alison thigh Tower Bonk
footing the bill okay uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Jaden who says rhaenys
was badass you know what my favorite bit
was the armor like one of my complaints
with the later seasons of Game of
Thrones is that we never got to see
Daenerys in armor when she was like
flying around in battle riding her
dragons like there was a moment in
season seven where they said like hey
Daenerys like it's really dangerous that
you're just flying around in battle
without any armor like an arrow could
hit you and kill you and Daenerys is
like yeah that's fine
um of course a Targaryen Monarch on a
dragon rider would wear some badass
armor like look at her bloody sleeveless
vest here can you imagine the the wind
chill flying around flying around in
that outfit
um that was always disappointing so I
glad I'm glad they've rectified that
with some badass armor you know and this
shows us that you know rhaenys is a doer
rhaenys is someone who like kicks ass
and gets [ __ ] done so uh she's gonna be
a useful asset as the story continues
she did put that armor on really quick
didn't she thanks for the Super Chat
from bdink who says I'm glad they're
making Allison and amond seem more gray
now yeah
um I I think that what they're doing
with Allison is interesting like in the
books it seems like Alison is in the
books elephant does not seem this
conflicted Alison seems just genuinely
genuinely determined to get her son
aegon on the throne and screw over
rainierer like um like Allison says you
know uh supposedly allegedly Alison says
in the book uh maybe that [ __ ] rhaenyra
will die in childbirth so Allison is not
sympathetic to Rainier at this point at
least as it's described in the books but
you know I think that given the
closeness that we saw between Alice and
Rainier last episode it makes sense that
you know Allison's Alison has remembered
her her love for her friend as children
and you know while she does want her
child on the throne she does not want
war she does not want to murder rhaenyra
so you know and so yeah I thought the
tension between Allison and Otto was so
interesting because because you know it
is important it is important not just
who is on the throne but how they get
that person on the throne you know like
if they can get aegon onto the throne
bloodlessly then maybe it would be okay
I mean it's like rhaenys says to Allison
like hey you know we can like Allison
says we do not rule but we may guide The
Men Who do and it's like yeah I mean
sure aegon is useless but if they guide
aegon or if they just rule on aegon's
behalf and just do the moral thing and
look after the realm then maybe it will
be okay like it's not necessarily all
that important who whose bum is on the
throne it's more important what
decisions are being made by the
government behind that person so I think
elephant makes sort of a good argument
here that you know
they could put aegon on the throne and
everything could be okay as long as they
don't start a giant goddamn War so
you know I still think it kind of
Beggars belief that Alison thinks that
viserys told her that aegon is king
um because you know at the end of last
episode Oliver Sarah said was like oh
the princess that was promised aegon's
dream you must do this you are the one
like it's kind of a stretch that Alison
really believes that that means that
viserys wants aegon to be king I think
that's very much like motivated
reasoning from Alison and and that is
another big weird change from the books
uh yeah thanks for the Super Chat from
dread who feat Emoji thank you bees man
who says whatever my daughter is paying
I will double it you have okay a lot of
feet comments thank you Samuel who says
showrunner said it was rainey's moral
standing that stopped her from torching
the hightowers
it was a cool moment and you needed to
justify season two I I look a lot of
people take issue with rainey's not
murdering all of the high Towers but
you've got to like keep in mind that
that rhaenys does not know the future
rainey's does not know what's gonna
happen next for all rainy snows for all
we know maybe rhaenyra and Alison will
make peace
um
there's a lot of different ways this
could go down and in hindsight things
might seem obvious but yeah I don't
think it's crazy that rainy's didn't
murder all of the greens right there I
did think it was crazy that the greens
didn't immediately run away when they
were faced with a giant fire breathing
dragon but there you go and you know
incidentally this is our first glimpse
of rhaenius's dragon melis the Red Queen
um so it's exciting to see her as well
if we want to do a little quick Dragon
accounting these are the dragons with
riders who exist currently
aegon aemond Helena have dragons on the
green side and rhaenyra Daemon rhaenys
Jace Luke and Baylor have dragons on the
black side
um Jace Luke and Baylor's dragons are
quite small young dragons they're not
quite as powerful like the most powerful
the most powerful the biggest and most
powerful Dragon right now is vegar
written by amond and then uh karaxi's is
probably the second most powerful Dragon
or maybe melis as well and Cyrax is
relatively young but also pretty
powerful so it's probably like Vega
karaxi's melee's dream fire I like the
most powerful and then like ver Max
arics Moon Dancer are the least powerful
Moondance is very young
I don't can Moon Dancer even bear
Baylor's weight right now Moondance is
very young so maybe not super relevant
but there are also lots of other dragons
that are around like there's vermouth or
and Silverwing uh which are big old
dragons and they are either in the
dragon pit or on Dragonstone and then
you've got like sea smoke who is Leno's
Dragon he's around and then you've got
more dragons that we'll learn about
later so these dragons are obviously
going to become more and more important
as The Story Goes On
there's lots of dragons around
thanks for the Super Chat from Flair who
says love the vids glad to see Cole
using a sword instead of a flail you
kept calling it a Morning Star yeah I
know there's like terminology around the
weapons I I just use whatever words the
books use I just use the terminology
that George Martin uses in the books and
in the books they call Kristen Cole's
weapon a Morning Star
um so you know I just followed the
book's lead
uh but yeah George definitely uses some
different terminology like George calls
like standard normal length swords long
swords that's what he calls just just
these normal ass swords that everyone
has
um whereas long swords in like real
history apparently are long thus the
name but yeah whatever terminology
thanks for the Super Chat from Flavor
who says was
Otto wanting to meet aegon outside the
city walls he wanted to send aegon away
and install aemond on the throne I I
don't think Otto wanted to reject aegon
and
make aemond King no
um I think that that was more about
getting aegon out of the city for like
safety or like getting him away from
Allison's control that was a bit weird
yeah
um but I don't think that Otto wants to
like get rid of aegon I think that in a
similar way to Alison saying that you
know we can just rule through aegon
I think that Otto also expects to
continue to be in charge
um of the realm as hand of the king if
not Regent like I think Otto intends to
have I think Otto thinks he can control
aegon I thought that Otto had such a
great line where he said that you know
what we are doing is is for the
interests of our family you know for the
good of the family is what Otto said
which just rangs so false because of how
messed up their family is and speaking
of their family I like that we got to
get a glimpse of uh Helena with her
children
um Helena is the sister and wife of
aegon and yeah here it is
um Helena was just chilling and doing
some some crocheting and these are
Helena and aegon's two children who are
called jehera and jahiris
um and Jerry's in the books incidentally
has uh six fingers on each hand and six
toes on each foot
uh so you know I'm sure we'll we'll see
more of it but joharis and Jahira are um
a little bit unusual in various ways
and I also liked the serving woman who
was like hanging out with Helena
and Helena was sort of uh philosophizing
about how you know Everyone likes to
take things from each other and you know
jealousy is the human nature and then
the serving woman was just like yes
princess yes of course yes
um I imagine that whoever works with
Helena has to be saying an awful lot of
smiling and nodding you know what I mean
Helena says some unusual things and her
servants would hear some unusual things
and I love that Helena was knitting like
a spider and Helena said again there is
a beast beneath the boards and like the
spider is like the symbol of mazario
because people were talking about
mazaria as a spider with a web of
informants so I think that Helena you
know consciously or not is expressing
her fear of the spies and the agents who
are using the secret tunnels and you
know that she she's afraid of everything
that's going on at the red keep and the
spider is a reflection of that
I thought it was funny that lariss
talked about bees
this episode a lot of people thought
that uh larus's Firefly symbol was a bee
because on on his staff he's got this uh
this this bug that you know some people
thought that was a b but apparently
according to the creators it's actually
a firefly so it's kind of funny and
confusing that you know we've got a lot
of like mixed insect metaphors going on
with bees and fireflies and spiders or
insects and arachnids it's a it's a
whole goddamn Menagerie here at the red
cape
thanks for the Super Chat from Charlie
who says melis smash or pass uh thanks
for the Super Chat from Lee who says the
White Worm can't be gone that fast do
you think Missouri is dead do you think
she burned in that house fire we will
have to find out what if she gets burned
by it what if she walks out of the fire
and becomes more angry and dangerous
than before I love how larys is like
signature move is awesome like that's
just his thing he just he just loves a
spot of arson
um whenever there's a mysterious
suspicious fire we will know who to
blame I think
thanks for the Super Chat from John who
says what was the building that was on
fire yes so Lara said hey if you want me
to murder mazaria I'll murder mazaria
and Allison's like yeah cool
um and so Laris burned the building
where I think this is the same building
where we saw Talia visit mazaria
previously so laros was trying to kill
mazaria with this fire and mazaria is
this woman who is the spymaster who
controls a lot of the spies in the red
keep and she used to be daemon's lover
and now she's not and she fed
information to Otto but she also has
like this agenda trying to protect
children and yeah mazaria lady Misery
the White Worm she goes by many names
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Haley
who says larys was my favorite character
until this episode still a banger
episode probably my favorite
fact says the omission of Lord
beesbury's defenestration was highly
disappointing I was hoping to see Lord
beesberry get thrown out the window
which is what mushroom says happened uh
Evan says Laris went from creepy to
really weird intriguing to creepy to
really weird yeah we haven't had very
many scenes with Laris but every scene
we learn something crazy about him like
the first time we saw him he's just like
ah he's just like this unassuming guy
with a deformed foot who likes eating
cookies and listening to chit chat cool
what what a what a innocuous dude and
then in episode five he just turns up
and says oh by the way I know about the
secret abortion tea I know about the
plan B and I have strong opinions about
flowers and all and he like started the
conflict between rhaenya and Alison like
let's not forget Lara is by telling
Allison and about the moon tea kind of
kicked off some of the some of the big
dangerous conflagrations that that came
and um so he's very much like the spark
that started this fire in so many ways
um
and then yeah in episode six he he
murdered his father and brother and uh
seemed really chuffed about it in
episode seven I I like the increasing
amounts of bling that we've seen on
Laris and on several others larys had
like a bunch of like fancy jewelry look
at this he like every episode he's got
fancier jewelry and it's similar with
like Thailand Lannister like I thought
like Thailand Lannister the the master
of coin and the brother of Jason
Lannister
when we first met Thailand he seemed
like the more sort of like
Earnest hard-working good-natured
brother like Jason Lannister was always
a douchebag he was the one who hit on
rhaenyra and he was really arrogant and
unpleasant whereas Thailand like was
just sort of this he was sort of
flustered and hardworking and doing his
best he didn't have any bling he was
just like working with the stepstones
and doing his best but I feel like as
the story has gone on Thailand now that
he has more power and more privilege he
has become a bit more arrogant
well I think Thailand has you know in a
subtle way become a worse dude as the
story has gone on I think power has
corrupted Thailand to some extent and
the gradual blinkification as he gets
fancier jewelry with his power and with
his wealth
um I think speaks to how people are
profiting from politics
um and that's how we end up with these
like corrupt messed up situations like
there are men who have a lot to gain by
siding with one side or the other like
Vermont when he tried to make that
alliance with the high Towers
um I enjoyed the scene where all of
those Lords were forced to kneel for the
um for the new king aegon and it was
this moment of like are you going to
kneel and profit from siding with us or
are you going to die and so Alan Caswell
made the choice of well all right I will
kneel I will pretend to join the side of
aegon even though I swore to support
rhaenyra because you know let's not
forget that in episode one
um King viserys declared that rhaenyra
was his Heir on the throne and all of
these Lords
swore to support rhaenyra
so all the Lords who were there who now
support aegon are oath Breakers but a
point that Thailand makes in the in Hot
D and in the show is that
a lot of the Lords and Ladies who were
here are dead now that was like 30 years
ago or something I mean the timeline is
different in the show I suppose
um it was a long time ago when this
happened and so people you know some of
these Lords are dead and their children
have inherited the Lordships and the
politics has shifted so people are not
all staying loyal
uh Chanel says that sir in cell lot got
away with murder again yeah I I mean I I
think we can expect an increasing
amounts of murder as The Story Goes On
if we're being honest
dick says why is there a more vocal
reaction to larus's preferences than
craster ever got we are living in the
strangest timeline I don't think people
I mean craster was that guy in Game of
Thrones
um who had a uh evil horrible incestuous
uh sex slave Harem Beyond the Wall
um I I don't think anyone thinks that
Laris is worse than that thanks for the
Super Chat from Jax who says I really
enjoyed the camera work they really do
know how to get good footage yeah there
were some interesting shots going on
throughout the series there's been some
interesting shots I liked in the
previous episode when the camera like
swept over the Iron Throne down to show
Otto on the throne there are some really
interesting
camera work going on AHS says do you
think mazaria is going to strike back
after getting her estate burned by
Alison and will that give Otto the
Reigns to control aegon instead of her
I think that Missouri uh
Missouri was already kind of
opposed to larus as like a rival
merchants of information I think like I
think what's interesting is that mazaria
has this like trying to protect the
people angle which is not an angle that
Lara says so I think yeah they are
fundamentally got different motivations
I suppose
um
and will that give Otto the reins to
control aegon yeah well that was what
happened Blake says there's another
element of rhaenys doing the opposite of
what she was being forced to do rhaenys
is defiant rhaenys is a rebel Rainey
said last episode that she wanted to
stand alone I I think that in a way she
was saying that like I'm I'm better than
this conflict you guys are doing and
like if I can walk away from this
conflict then you guys should walk away
from this conflict too I like how this
was the um like with all the trappings
of political legitimacy that they were
trying to summon this chair in the
background of the coronation scene is
the same chair that we saw at the
harrenhall council in season one episode
one
uh this chair that joharis is sitting on
I think it's the same one you see that
design
same or or is it slightly different
yeah well very similar chair anyway
Gabriella says rhaenys definitely did
that to ensure that if the greens win
she can get some sort of pardon I don't
know if that's a good defense in court
your honor I could have murdered you but
didn't
Edo says was the beast beast beneath the
boards rhaenys and her dragon
that is uh a cool interpretation because
yeah like Melisandre melis and rainies
were a beast that literally burst up
from from beneath the floorboards at the
dragon pit so yeah that's a great point
I think in a way melis could be seen as
a fulfillment of that prophecy
um but I don't think the Beast beneath
the boards thing has ended yet
thanks for the Super Chat from Flavor we
answered that one thanks for the Super
Chat from Oz who says yeah the feral
child fighting ring we've all seen it
it was interesting how they specified
that like with these children who were
forced to fight each other for
entertainment they mentioned that like
the gold cloaks or the City Guards
except bribes in order to allow this
stuff to continue so it's a reminder of
political corruption I mean I guess you
know this is a time of prosperity this
is a time when there's a lot of money
around in in the city and in the Dynasty
and so I guess with all of that money
lying around that's an opportunity for
corruption and bad things to go on I
mean it sort of fits with the theme of
decadence the showrun has talked a lot
about decadence in this time and so we
see all the big feasts and balls and
dances and elaborate costumes and
showing off all of this wealth but
there's also a kind of decadence like an
evil decadence in these like pits of
depravity of like drinking and sex and
slavery and gambling and fighting and
all of those traditional uh sins that
are going on that's like another angle
to the to the decadence and the
Indulgence that's going going on both at
the highest of the city and at the
lowest and the lowest is where aegon
liked to enjoy himself and yeah aegon is
such a monster like aegon not only raped
Diana last episode but aegon is is
participating in these like child fights
on the regular apparently and you know
what happens to the children
like the bastard children that aegon
leaves here in the fighting bits what
happens to these kids do they get is
aegon allowing his bastard children to
be made into child slave pit fighters
with failed teeth is that what is that
what's going to happen to this bastard
child of the king
I I wonder if mazaria might take control
of this child in the same way that
mazaria took control of aegon
lots of crazy possibilities
thanks for the Super Chat from
Matthew who says the queen Who Never Was
is so gangster
Nick says that rhaenys didn't crisp the
blacks because their family and
kinslaying is serious and she's followed
the law Yeah well yeah that's another
good point like these families are all
intermarried the valerians and
targaryens so she's not gonna like
murder her own family
that would be a wild escalation and a
sin that she would be hated for forever
thanks for the Super Chat from Gunner
who says loving the performance of
Helena yeah I love how Helena is like
simultaneously really sort of like naive
and seems to like not know what's
happening sometimes but in other ways in
other ways she's like the most
insightful person in the room
um and seeing the tragedy of her like
you know warning of the Beast beneath
the boards and the spider that she's
drawing
um
and she's so innocent of all of the
[ __ ] that's gone down
wasn't her choice to be married to Akon
but now she is the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms Helena is the queen now and I
wonder if she might Embrace some kind of
political power that would be cool maybe
she's actually gonna I mean she's the
bug Queen now
she's the entomologist Queen maybe she's
going to uh look after the bugs of
King's Landing that would be fun too
uh yeah she was not having a great time
at the coronation no
um like I I don't like you know I mean
one of the ironies of this show is that
everyone is fighting tooth and nail to
take control of the throne and to be in
charge of government but being in the
government at least you know for the
king and queen especially it does not
make their lives better like and aegon
knows this like aegon knows that being
king is not going to make his life
better it's going to put him in more
danger and more stress and more
responsibility that he doesn't want it's
really the people around the king and
queen the people who the Puppet Masters
who control these figureheads like Otto
like they are the people who really
benefit you know the Lords and the
suck-ups and the brown noses those are
the people who benefit from putting
someone on the throne
um and yeah it's no fun it's no fun so I
feel sorry for Helena especially
Furman says what were the intentions of
Otto versus Allison I think the
fundamental difference between Otto and
Alison in this episode was that
Otto and Thailand and Jasper were
willing to escalate this conflict and
they wanted to capture and kill rhaenyra
and her children because as long as
rhaenyra and her children are alive they
are a Potential Threat to aegon King
aegon II
whereas Allison did not want to kill
rhaenyra and she was hoping to give
Rainier a peace terms that rhaenyra
would agree to Alison was trying to find
a more peaceful resolution to this
conflict whereas Otto was basically
saying that no like like
violence is inevitable so let's strike
fast
that's the main difference between Otto
and Allison so they were both trying to
take control of the king because when
you have the king uh you've you've got
the power and you can set the terms so
that was that was the disagreement and
this is such a big deal for for Allison
because she has spent her whole life
following
um her father's wishes and now she
finally stands up against him
which is a big deal thanks for the Super
Chat from Suka who says did anything new
show up in the opening yeah the opening
sequence was updated radically
um I haven't had time to like properly
look through it but yeah they did change
it so here's like joharis and alisane
um and in the background we can see the
valerions and there is viserys
and then we go down to the star is that
Allison is Alison has Alison now got a
seven-pointed star as her schedule it
used to just be a Hightower sigil but
now Alison has her own sigil the faith
of the seven that she was wearing on her
necklace and then we've got yeah all
right we've got we've got four
Bloodlines so in the in the books
um Allison and viserys have four
children they have aegon Helena amond
and a boy called dayron
and the show's creators have said that
there will be uh dayron will turn up in
season two so I I think that represents
dayron
um and dayron I think currently is is
being fostered at Old Town because that
that's what happens in the books so
there is another child who we're gonna
meet later on uh then these other three
so I suppose this is aegon and Helena
and amont these three sigils that bright
blue sigil is interesting
um super super minor minor minor mild
spoiler but there was a moment in the
preview trailer for The Next Episode
that showed amond taking his eye patch
off and I wonder if that bright blue
thing represents a sapphire under amon's
eye
um because the books mentioned that am I
remembering that correctly I think the
books mentioned that aemond wears a
sapphire in his empty eye socket under
his eye patch as if amond needed to be
more of a
an anime villain uh bird guy so I think
that might be what that blue represents
um this symbol for Helena it looks like
a female figure on like a round thing it
looks like a woman like tied to a
boulder or something crazy I I I mean
representing our Helena is like trapped
or something that is dark and weird
um and the aegon sigil
not sure what that one represents maybe
it's meant to be aegon's crown or
blackfyre or something like that
um let's continue through the opening
sequence
I suppose those are yeah those must be
Jairus and Jahira
um the children of aegon and Helena
there's actually three children of aegon
and Helena
uh with this episode we saw Jairus and
Jahira but there's also a younger son
called maylor so I suppose that's what
these three are and see how jahiris and
jihara are represented by hands and I
and I just said that the Harris and
Jahira have Audrey Harris at least has
six fingers on each hand and six toes on
each foot so Laris would love Jairus I
guess
um so yeah I guess these are the three
children of Helena and aegon and then
further down
is this going to be Rainier's Bloodline
with Harwin
who are these two are these Baylor and
Rayna I thought Baylor and Reina would
dragon eggs previously
who were those two meant to be
where or are they or is that like Jace
and
Luke
yeah I'll have to have a proper look at
the opening sequence later
anyway
um
yeah I I've said before I don't think
the opening sequence is very helpful for
figuring out the family tree if you want
to know the family tree just just just
just just ask your old buddy old shift X
here's here's a family tree where you
can actually see what's going on
these are the children so yeah like
aegon and Helena have a have a third
child May law at this point in the books
and viserys and Alison have a fourth
child called dayron at this point in the
books but these are the characters that
we've actually seen on the show so far
and you know for the record like you
know aegon the the newly crowned King
aegon II is referred to as the Elder
to distinguish him from aegon the other
aegon the son of rhaenyra and Daemon
who's a baby and he's called the younger
so I've got aegon the Elder and aegon
the younger and we've also got you know
baby viserys who I suppose is viserys
the younger lots of reused names just to
keep it confusing there was a scene in
the previous episode that had uh rhaenys
Raina and rhaenyra all in the same scene
which seemed like a like a joke to have
so many characters with similar names
all in the same sequence
um anyway thanks for the Super Chat from
Cal who says I hope lanor gets word and
comes back to fight you know he loves a
good War yeah that's a that's a good
point like like the only things that
Leno really showed interest in uh were
like partying with his boyfriends and
War
like he's a really lovely guy but when
you look at his actual Hobbies he um his
hobbies are you know war and partying
um and yeah he was like whooping and
hollering and you know enjoying the the
pod racing element of of riding sea
Smoke on the stepstones so maybe if they
just like send send lean or a raven
maybe Lenor would row right the hell
back and help out with any potential
conflict that may come
I I want to know what's going on with
sea smoke because again like it is a
change from the books that lane or is
alive because in the show in the books
lane or seems to be really dead and so
that does leave this loose thread of
like what's going on with sea smoke can
see smoke a bond with a new Rider while
Leonor is still alive
really interesting
really interesting questions with say
smoke
Stone says that melis looked kind of
cartoonish and the sound design wasn't
great I thought the sound of melis was
good but yeah the CGI has not always
been amazing Co black says it's
interesting that there's not a lot of
Judgment of rhaeny's killing innocent
poor people with her dragon
could be seen as a worse impact than
aegon's acts a reminder that no one is
100 good or bad in Game of Thrones yeah
I mean it's a good reminder that even
like the quote-unquote good guys and the
bad guys in this story they're all
feudal Warlords basically like everyone
in this story
um is a politician who holds power
through the threat of violence which you
know is maybe true of all politicians
hashtag topical but like I think that
yeah I mean rainy's rainey's murked a
bunch of innocent poor people in this
moment and she she probably should have
gone out the back way
she she there's multiple exits from the
dragon pit and she chose to go through
the floor that innocent peasants were
standing on so you know and again like
with Jorah like when the high Lords play
their Game of Thrones it's it's the
innocent people who suffered but like
two you know Alice and and rainey's as
credit
in this conversation
um you know they were saying hey like we
have to yeah look at this Allison says
we must guide them gently away from
violence and destruction and instead
towards peace and they talked about like
the the interests of the common people
so a true Queen counts the cost to her
people so if you're looking for a moral
defender of the Common People you should
be supporting Alison because Allison is
I I think in this show the one person
who has been most consistently speaking
for protecting the common people and
doing good for the realm and I think
sometimes that has been [ __ ] I think
sometimes Allison's virtue has been a
cloak of righteousness quote unquote but
Alison tabs repeatedly said hey let's
protect the people so to her credit you
know she is the one saying that
um she hasn't murdered people she isn't
trying to start a war so I think she's
cool
thanks for the Super Chat from Sir Aki
mad dude who says what exactly drove
apart Eric and Eric yeah it wasn't super
clear in the episode like what the rift
between arik and Eric was it wasn't
super clear what went down there but in
the inside the episode after show the
the creators were saying that like
basically that Eric had more of a moral
compass and Eric was like not a fan of
the child pit fights whereas Eric is
like I'm just following orders I'll
stick with aegon so so that's why Eric
and Eric went separate ways
um and Eric stayed to like fight Kristen
for control of aegon which was all kind
of confusing because Kristen was trying
to bring aegon to Alison and Eric was
trying to bring aegon to Otto it was
sort of a weird you know I I it's a
weird thing that wasn't in the books
it's sort of a weird like internal power
struggle but um but the point is that
arik and Eric have split up and Eric has
gone to rhaenyra and Harold westerling
has gone terrain era presumably when he
left the greens
or maybe he hasn't I don't know but yeah
the King's Guard has become politicized
which is like not great it's I mean it's
a little bit like when the Supreme Court
gets politicized like they are meant to
be unbiased and apolitical but they have
power so inevitably they do become
politicized and they do become divided
so it becomes a a problem when this you
know supposedly impartial institution
becomes itself another Battleground
thanks for the Super Chat from Kion who
says I wonder if princess rainey's
targaryen's skill in Dragon riding can
outperform a Mont Targaryen due to
having much more experience by decades
yeah I think that's a great point
because there is like a generational
difference here like amond is Young
aemond is meant to be like 19 years old
in the book at this point
um and yeah aemond has the most powerful
Dragon in the world but like can aemond
even control like can aemond handle that
much dragon rainis is a goddamn veteran
like 50 something year old woman who who
you know Dragon riding has been her
passion for decades and it takes time to
develop that Bond you know
um so I think that rhaenys's control of
merely should be like Sublime like she
should really know what she's doing
um but I think also you know like there
is sort of an implication I think
um at least in the show and sometimes in
the books that that dragons do have a
sort of their own personality and
there's sometimes maybe a psychic
connection between the dragon and their
Rider so I feel like vegar herself could
um be in control like like vegar is the
most experienced warrior in this world
because vegar is the oldest dragon in
this world and um I think that Vega
could more than handle herself I think
amond could just come along for the ride
you know I think amon's expertise may
not even be relevant compared to the
sheer power and experience of Vega
um like if rainis is like the old sort
of like powerful badass Grandma of the
humans Vega is the old powerful Grandma
of the dragons
so yeah there's a lot of goddamn power
and history in some of these oldies
compared to these um young upstarts and
I think that you know something that the
previous episode got across really well
is that the older the older people the
adults like they are more mature they
have experienced loss they have
experienced pain and so they are more
reluctant to start a war with them with
the notable exception of Otto
um whereas the young kids like amond and
Jace and Luke they are full of spunk and
Bluster and they are super willing to
start fisticuffs at the drop of a hat so
I think some of the worst violence may
come from the kids whereas the adults
who may be more powerful are a bit more
restrained usually
I want to see more from Baylor and Reyna
as well like I think that next episode
we're going to see you know Rainier's
perspective because this whole episode
took place from the greens perspective
with Allison and Otto and and Kristen
and aegon name on where is next episode
I think will be from the perspective of
rhaenyra and Daemon and Jace and Luke
um and Rayna so it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens on the
next episode
thanks for the Super Chat from doser Doc
who says what happened to Sea smoke the
dragon of Lenor we don't know can lane
or bond with someone new we don't know
Carl says is Helena's depiction in the
show faithful to the books so far seems
like a cool character Helena is
different in the show compared to the
books in the books Helena gets like
almost no description at all they just
say in the books that oh Helena is like
less hot than other targaryens uh she's
but she's plump and happy and will be a
good mother that's that's like the
extent of the description of Elena in
the books so I think that in the show
they they made a really good choice by
giving Helena this sort of insight and
this awareness that sort of she can say
these cryptic revealing things to us as
the audience and they give her all this
like subtle characterize station that
doesn't like dramatically impact the
plot itself so like there's nothing
about Helena's character that
contradicts the books but it definitely
adds a lot more layers and depth to
Helena as a character like they added
the bug interest they added the sort of
neurodivergent aspect they added the
cryptic sayings so I think that like so
many other characters in this show that
the show has done a really good job of
taking what's in the book and adding to
it without like totally contradicting it
uh thank you wealthwolf we are not going
to spoil anything in the future but um
yeah I would certainly keep an eye on
that bastard child of aegon who we saw
in the uh child fighting pits which is
not a phrase I was expecting to use
thanks for the Super Chat from Buster
Destroyer who says speaking of all the
male sexuality icking Alison out
Otto made that comment about her looking
like her mother felt manipulative and
odd yes I completely agree Buster and I
meant to say that yeah because like that
that angle of like Allison seeming
grossed out by all the horny men around
her I I think in a way that includes her
father yeah because like her father made
this weird comment about how Allison
looks like her mother
um and it just felt a bit icky like I
remember when Otto told Alison to put on
her mother's dress in order to go and
seduce the king
like there's an ickiness to it and that
just inherently comes from like the
intimacy and the sexuality of this royal
family like who boned who is of National
Security importance so like all of these
family members have huge political
investment in their like families sex
lives and that just creates this
ickiness this incestuous intimacy
between everybody all the time and it's
just [ __ ] gross
KO says
no aemon's B kids will be recruited to
fight and ride dragons not sure what
you're saying but like there is the
issue of like who can ride dragons like
I mean that that's going to be something
that's discussed next episode is like
who has the weapons of war right now and
you know we we discussed the dragon
accounting before like these are the
Dragons Who currently have Riders but
there are other dragons who don't have
Riders and every Targaryen blooded
person who doesn't have a dragon is a
potential Dragon Rider will Joffrey
valarion son of rhaenyra get a dragon
will Reina finally get a dragon will
baby Jahira and joheris get dragons and
ride them with their with their 12 toes
and 12 Fingers
um
the dragon riding aspect is important
dasan says why do the showrunners write
Alison to act like she has no agency
especially with Laris even as a grown
woman she doesn't have any Drive of her
own I think that the point of some of
these scenes was about Alice and seizing
her agency like Alison was saying to
Otto like hey you have like manipulated
me you have treated me as a pawn my
whole life you have used me and I'm not
gonna accept that anymore so I'm gonna
seize aegon for myself and I'm gonna do
things my way and I'm going to take the
throne but not start a war so I think
this was about Alison seizing her
um agency but I mean that's definitely
like a complex theme throughout Alison's
Ark right because you know like she has
always felt like she doesn't have
freedom she has always felt trapped in
the expectations of court and in the
expectations of her father and in the
expert of her husband and there's a lot
of moments where it's like Alison is not
comfortable with the position that she's
in but she feels like she has to go
along with it
um but you know we can compare that to
rhaenyra because rhaenyra like in theory
is under a lot of the same pressures and
expectations but while Alison obeys
raniera often Rebels
so it's like you know Alison you could
say is going along with pressures that
maybe she could have resisted more like
you know right Allison now is finally
rebelling against Otto but it's like
maybe she should have done that sooner
and I think that as Alison grows up
instead of like rejecting the powers
that control her she instead embraced
them and used them as a tool like the
whole like you know a woman's courtesy
is her armor and using the faith and the
religion and using like the uh moral
religious laws and and rules of this
world she has weaponized them and when
she finally stands up and asserts her
power it's not with the sword it's not
with the dragon it's it's with a dress
so so she is always like embraced and
weaponized that like traditional
feminine power within the patriarchal
system
um and I think that we see that most
visibly when she intimidates Diana the
serving girl who was raped by aegon and
Allison is like sympathetic but at the
same time she's also like reinforcing
and participating in this [ __ ] up
patriarchal system so yeah I mean I I'm
probably not I'm not the most qualified
person to uh expound on it but I think
that all the ideas around Allison's
agency and within the system that she
exists I think is definitely a complex
theme for her Arc
thanks for the Super Chat from Eugenia
who says aegon is just a supportive dad
cheering for his children during their
Sports activity in the after-school
program of the flea bottom education
system
foreign
you're not wrong like aegon is just a
soccer mom you know like I bet aegon is
coming and bringing some orange slices
and snacks for his bastard children you
know giving them a Gatorade after they
after their
off after their Fight Club
um yeah aegon I'm sure has the best of
intentions with his bastard children of
course thanks for the Super Chat from
Beth who says I think that a dragon
coming from under your floor is a bad
Omen yeah it's cool the way that they
did that I because you know dragons
dragons are often depicted as like these
Subterranean beasts who like lurk in
caves and and jealously hoard gold like
Smaug and so I think you know getting to
see the dragons in like the Subterranean
volcanic
um habitat was really cool like in the
previous episode we got to see the
dragon eggs being laid in the dragonmont
um and we got to see
um I think it was dream fire like under
the dragon pit in a previous episode
when amond went down there and so yeah
like like it is really cool that you
know and as we should we are are getting
more glimpses of like what dragons are
and how they work you know these are
animals that have their own sort of
bizarre magical anatomy and biology and
and system and and you know getting to
see more glimpses of that symbolically
and in the lore it's really cool
uh we've discussed the opening sequence
Jesus or Jesus says did they even mourn
King viserys yeah I mean that's the
that's the tragedy of all of this like
you know a lot of people here really did
genuinely love viserys Alison really
genuinely had a lot of concern for
viserys I mean I think that an angle
that's really cool is that like
they made it very clear like especially
in interviews that the reason why or one
of the main reasons why King viserys was
so determined to support rhaenyra as his
Heir was because viserys always loved
his wife Emma his first wife Emma the
mother of rhaenyra and he never stopped
loving her and ever since Emma died in
that horrific C-section viserys felt
horrifically guilty about Emma's death
and he wanted to make Rainier air as a
tribute to Emma and a Penance for Emma's
death and I think that in a similar way
and maybe this is me reading too much
into it but I feel like Emma sorry
Allison when viserys died and when
Alison thought viserys said that he
wants her son aegon to be king
I think maybe Alison is thinking I must
make aegon King as a
gesture of my love for viserys because
you know Alison and viserys had a [ __ ]
up relationship but Alison cared for
viserys Alison showed a lot of love and
care for viserys and you know rhaenyra
came in last episode saying oh you're
just manipulating him and to some extent
that might be true but but I think you
know Alison was there for viserys in a
way that no one else was and I think
that Allison loved viserys in a way that
no one else did and so when Alison you
know now that she believes that viserys
wanted aegon to be king I think Alison
wants to honor that partly because of
her love for viserys and it's wrong and
it's misplaced but I think that it may
be a good intention so I think that I I
liked that we got a moment where
um where we saw viserys's body being
being like mummified by the silent
sisters and Alison was like crying for
him and putting a crown on on viserys's
body and and you're right that like yeah
like why is why are there not more
people mourning viserys everyone else is
off you know trying to get political
advantage and trying to start wars but
Alison is like the only one who was
there mourning the death of her husband
who she loved so I think that's another
sort of sympathetic aspect to Alison's
character right now
thanks for the Super Chat from Hunter
who says there's only one more episode
in the season yeah that's correct do you
envision there being a second season uh
there most certainly is a second season
Hunter it has been officially green lit
and it's going to take I think the show
run has said it'll take like three or
four seasons to tell this story
um and yeah we are just getting started
we are just getting started like this
whole first season so far has really
just mostly been backstory this has just
been set up this is about like learning
about the characters and their history
and their relationships the main event
has not even begun like the whole first
season has been like a family drama it's
been like this intimate slow very sort
of relationship based personality based
family drama
the later seasons are going to be a
little bit different and uh yeah that's
when the real [ __ ] begins
Natalie says do you think it means
anything that Helena purposefully looked
away when they said behold your king
yeah Helena does not like aegon because
he is a rapist and a drunkard and and
not a good person
um they mentioned last episode Helena
saying that aegon ignores her except for
when he's drunk and I don't imagine
aegon is nice to Helena when he is drunk
um and so yeah like I don't think Helena
is a fan of aegon and I do think it is
significant like the the sort of series
of nods that we saw from the various
characters like aegon looked at each
person and each person gave aegon a nod
in turn except I think for aemon did did
amond
not nod for aegon oh no yeah all right
aemond did do a little nod but you know
that there was a lot of like Envy in
that look from amond because aemond
wants aegon's Throne
um so it was you know it's a good sort
of reminder of where yeah and Helena
looks away it's a good reminder of where
their relationships stand with all these
people like the greens are not are not a
completely united front as a faction
there's plenty of Divisions within as
well as without so um yeah those
Dynamics are going to be really
important
thanks for the Super Chat from colorful
who says how did they get all those
Lords in the throne room in like two
hours to bend the knee so yeah there was
a scene when they shut the doors of the
red keep and they had all these Lords
and they were forcing them to swear
loyalty to aegon these Lords were
already at court like you're right like
that there wasn't time to like send out
Ravens and get all of these Lords from
all the kingdoms to come to the red
keeper these were just courtiers and
Lords who were already there that's one
of the things that house of the Dragon
has done a good job of emphasizing is
that like the court is meant to be a
hive of political activity like it's
it's like in Game of Thrones The Red
keep often seemed quite empty but you
know especially now in this time of like
prosperity and and you know lots of
people around there are lots of Lords
and courtiers and second sons and you
know
ambassadors from afar and and money
changers and and ambassadors and all
sorts of
political agents in the red cape trying
to push for their various political
agendas and these Lords are among them I
think so that's that's where they came
from
it's kind of reminiscent of when um
Theon took over Winterfell in um Game of
Thrones and he similarly like forced
people to swear loyalty to him but like
as we saw with Alan Caswell you know the
Loyalty of of people who you you know
force with threats they're not really
that loyal to you so Alan tried to act
against the greens and died for it
thanks for the Super Chat from Musa who
says amond and Kristen's relationship
fascinates me yeah they went on a fun
little buddy Mission out into the city
to try and find aegon
um and yeah I mean Kristen and amond
that they seem to have become close
um because Kristen and Amon like Kristen
has been training amond
um and I think that they are similar
characters in the sense that they are
both they've got big chips on their
shoulder like Kristen feels spurned and
rejected and bitter about what happened
between him and rhaenyra
and aemond feels better and angry about
the loss of his eye and we learned this
episode that he also feels better that
aegon gets to be heir to the throne when
aemond considers himself to be uh more
qualified how do we feel about Kristen's
Hat by the way interesting hat there I
think it's not as cool as Rainier as
beanie in episode four but anyway yeah I
think that amond and Kristen are a nice
Dynamic like I think that they
understand each other and and there are
a lot of similarities between them and
they both uh hate Daemon so that's
another thing that they've got in common
I suppose
um and they are both very badass
Warriors so yeah they got they got a lot
in common
Krispy Kreme Kristen Cole thanks to the
super jump from Marty who says very
interesting that Alison had to protect
the king when melis threatened the
greens not a good look for the king yeah
when rainy's burst out on melis
um the the the great and powerful King
aegon II uh coward behind his mother
Alison
um where is he yeah here he is King
aegon the mighty wielder of the of the
storied Valyrian blade blackfyre wearing
the crown of the Conqueror standing
behind his mother and you know it's nice
to see Allison's you know maternal
protective instincts kicking in there
Alison putting her body on the line to
protect aegon not that it would help but
you know it's it's nice to see Alison
being protective of aegon even though
she hates aegon I really enjoyed the
conversation between aegon and Alison in
the on the way to the coronation
um you know and aegon said Do You Love
Me mother and she said you're an
imbecile aegon which was such a cruel
thing to say
um but you know he did just rape someone
last episode so maybe that's why Allison
feels that way but you know I thought it
was so funny that that Alison was saying
ah it's this important sacred thing
viserys's dying wishes for you to be
king and aegon does not even entertain
the possibility he's like no you're full
of [ __ ] because viserys never liked me
and viserys always wanted rhaenyra to be
Heir and if he wanted to change his mind
he could have done so at any point in
the last 20 years so it's funny that
aegon is you know barely invested at all
in being King he doesn't want any of
this political stuff going on but it's
aegon who says the truth which is no
you're full of [ __ ] there's no way that
viserys wanted me to be king because I'm
[ __ ] look at me why would anyone want me
to be king this is [ __ ] so aegon is
the one telling the truth which is so
funny because you know aegon because he
he has
because he's not invested and because
he's not interested that's that's how
he's able to see the situation clearly
you know
and he does have all this resentment
towards viserys not loving him and
Allison not loving him and and as I said
I thought it was really cool how aegon
enjoyed the Adoration of the common
people and I think that's such a cool
Arc for aegon to be this person who
feels unloved he finds love for the
first time in his life from the common
people as king and so that's how he
becomes emotionally attached to being
King when previously he didn't want to
be
thank you laslin yeah I agree that you
know Laris fetishizing feat makes sense
given that Laris has a deformed foot
thank you Derek who says how do you feel
about blackfyre I thought it looked
great wish we could have seen it in Game
of Thrones yeah so blackfyre is the
storied Valyrian blade of aegon the
Conqueror
um and it is
um
it is an important symbol of political
legitimacy we have seen it a few times
um in this season
viserys used blackfyre as a walking
stick previously uh you know because
viserys is not much of a warrior I mean
there's this whole thing in
um in a later story about the blackfyre
rebellions where you know Daemon
blackfyre gets the sword blackfyre
because he's a warrior
um whereas his trueborn brother Daron
Targaryen did not get blackfyre because
he wasn't a warrior and that's sort of
similar to how viserys has this
incredible most badass sword in the
world but he
can't use it you know and I and I don't
think aegon can either like we have not
seen aegon fight particularly oh I mean
we did get that training scene where
aegon was where aegon was fighting
against Jace um but you know aegon does
not appear to be like a noted Warrior
whereas his little brother amond is
clearly very badass with the sword so I
would speculate that you know amon's
Envy of aegon includes aemond wanting
aegon's sword I bet amond would love to
take
aegon sword because of course Valyrian
steel it's strong and sharp and light of
the lyric every great warrior wants
Valyrian steel uh it's like maegor the
cruel he he wanted blackfyre so you know
and there is also a dark sister is the
other important ancestral Targaryen
Valyrian sword and Daemon currently has
dark sister
um so I bet amond would would love to
get dark sister if not blackfyre so keep
an eye on the Valyrian steel I mean one
of the significant points for Valyrian
steel in the main Game of Thrones show
is the Valyrian steel can kill white
walkers
other swords can't
um so
I you know I guess I guess it's not as
important in House of the Dragon unless
any white walkers turn up thanks for the
Super Chat from colorful shadows and
from Jones City who says Helena was the
creepy kid who sees who says random
things and can see ghosts can probably
do telekinesis and Float I think she's
definitely some kind of X-Men mutant
situation professor's Avia type thing
um I want I wonder like you know like
presumably Helena is able to see the
future like you know remember Helena
said oh aemond will have to close an eye
in order to get a dragon you know
um
and presumably Helena sees the future
through Dragon dreams because lots of
targaryens have dreams of the future
that often involve dragons like daeyron
the drunken and like you know Daenerys
and Jon Snow have prophetic dreams and
um but that's not the only way to have
prophetic Visions there's also like the
green seers can see through the magic of
the old gods and there's also people who
have glass candles like quaff possibly
so there's lots of different ways to be
plugged into magic
um and yeah I suppose it's Dragon dreams
with Elena but I bet but she hasn't
talked about dreams is the interesting
thing like viserys when he had prophetic
dreams was was talking about it as I had
a dream where this happened whereas
Helena just sort of states it as fact I
wonder if Elena is almost having like
dreams in Waking Life you know like like
and maybe that's why she's disconnected
from normal daily life like she seems
like she's in another world half the
time I wonder if Helena is just seeing
her dreams in real time and that's sort
of part of why she is disconnected from
reality like because Dragon dreams can
drive people a bit mad in the books
Dragon dreams can torment people like
they they are on the drunken so I think
Elena is a cool Riff on the law as being
someone who has dreams but is sort of
affected by them in a in a difficult way
I think
um Helena paste
thank you for the Super Chat from the
song yeah Cassandra in Greek myth
command he says in the live chat yeah
wasn't was Cassandra the one who like
she had the visions of the future but no
one listened to her and she was
tormented by no one listening to her
seeing the Doom coming but she couldn't
save herself
definitely some Vibes there I mean yeah
ever since the bloody Greeks there's
been stories of you know oracles
you can see the future but it never
works out for you you know there's
always a tragic dangerous element to the
prophecy just like you know Alison
dangerously misinterpreting viserys's
words about prophecy
and thanks for the Super Chat from
desorn who says that rainy's bursting
through the dragon pit
but choosing not to doesn't make sense
she decided not to murder a bunch of her
family and you know she doesn't know
what's going to happen next she doesn't
know that it would prevent a war to kill
all those people
um I I think it's reasonable for iranies
to not murder all those people but she
did kill a lot of peasants thanks for
the Super Chat from yeah trash said the
same thing wandering kangaroo says I
love the lines from aegon being loved I
think of viserys being neglectful of his
other children is showing I mean there
was that line a couple of episodes ago
where viserys said uh my only child
rhaenyra is my only child
I I think that viserys half the time
does not even remember that aegon and
Elena and amond exist
um
he very much like his his brain sort of
stopped at the point where Emma died and
I think that emotionally viserys always
stayed in the mindset of Emma as his
wife and rhaenyra is his child
so yeah I think viserys absolutely
failed as a father to aegon and Helena
and amond which which is all the more
tragic because like he he never should
have had those children in the first
place you know like he didn't need to
marry Allison and have those children in
the first place no one wanted him to
marry alicent except for Otto least of
all Alison herself like remember viserys
was going against everyone's wishes when
he married Alison instead of Lena
valerion if viserys was serious about
supporting rhaenyra he should have been
focusing more on getting rhaenyra
married and producing ears which you
know he was trying to do but it was
viserys's choice to have children with
Allison that created this conflict
um if viserys's pull-out game was a
little bit better this war would never
have happened that's all I'm saying
thanks for the Super Chat from Cesar
Borg who says aemond believing that he
should be the one taking the crown is
interesting also saying the Kristen is a
decent man with no taste for depravity
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Clayton who says it's neat how the
dragons are all related like the
targaryens and they end up being not
nice to each other yeah I mean the
dragons and the targaryens
um they are all intertwined literally I
mean we've seen on all of these
tapestries in the background right that
like the the targaryens and the dragons
uh have been having incestuous sex with
each other just as the targaryens uh are
an ancestuous messed up royal family I
can't even show this on YouTube is how
racy these Dragon orgy murals are
um
so yeah yeah the the activities of the
Dragons reflect the the targaryens and
we saw like you know Cyrax facing off
with caraxis in episode two as well like
yeah the relationships between the
dragons are something that I hope we get
to explore more and you know I've also
seen the idea thrown around that you
know maybe the reason why caraxis has
such a strange body like the showrunners
have described karaxi's as a deformed
Dragon because he has a super long neck
and he's got Wings on his hind legs and
he's all a bit weird like joharis and
johera the children of Alison and uh the
children of Helena and aegon who have
six fingers on each hand and six toes on
each foot like the the strange body
shapes seem to go along with the incest
like Matt Damon's Habsburg chin so um
yeah I think there's definitely
parallels there
thanks for and and fundamentally it
comes from the like hoarding of power
like the reason why the targaryens marry
themselves and only allow the dragons to
be controlled by targaryens is because
the targaryens are hoarding power the
power in their blood the power of the
throne the power of Magic the power of
dragons that's why they are so
incestuous and so in a metaphorical way
you know their their power lust
um is what leads to their downfall and
their physical deformities like you know
even viserys's leprosy disease you know
maybe that in some sense was a
consequence of the years of inbreeding
because like this they go hard with the
incest
um like you know aegon married both of
his sisters Anis in the books married a
valerion which is you know probably a
cousin jahiris and alisane siblings
Balon and Alyssa siblings so viserys is
like a superb incest baby it's a it's a
wonder he's as as
um you know
his his DNA is like a ball of yarn
thanks for the Super Chat from loads who
says where was house Stark in the throne
room yeah there's a bit of confusion
about this this scene there is
definitely going to be conversations
about the great Lords of Westeros these
Lords who who bowed to a Otto they are
not all the Lords in the Kingdom they
were just the few Lords who happened to
be in the red keep at the time
um
we can take a look at who the who the
great Lords are at the moment if you'd
like here's a political map of the Great
Lords of Westeros like we have met Jason
Lannister the Lord of casterly rock
um and uh we met uh Borum and Baratheon
the father of boros Baratheon boros has
now taken over at least in the books
um Dalton Greyjoy the red Kraken is in
charge of the iron Islands they
mentioned Jane Aaron the lady of the
veil uh kriegen Stark is up in the north
um and you know Lord Hobart Hightower
and Lord call us valarion are probably
the two of the most powerful Lords in
the realm even though they are not
officially great Lords
um they don't rule an entire Kingdom the
hightowers are at least in theory
subservient to the tyrells and the
valerions are at least in theory
subservient to the targaryens so these
are all like the really important Lords
that we're going to be having
conversations about as The Story Goes On
um whereas these Lords are not
Ultra important like Lord Caswell and
Lord fell are not the people who Rule
the Kingdom
thanks for the Super Chat from desorn
and from Jess who says Thailand is just
an upstart second son just like vemond
but with a worse complex because he's a
younger twin yeah I mean there's been a
lot of talk this this series about like
you know Second Son syndrome how you
know Daemon feels jealous and messed up
of viserys aemond feels jealous and
messed up with aegon vemond as you say
and yeah I think we might be seeing that
from Thailand like maybe part of why
Thailand is so eager for war and he's
been plotting with Otto to install aegon
to you know increase his power and get
increasingly more fancy golden necklaces
for himself is that a euphemism uh I
think it's this like Second Son
inferiority complex for sure
um and being a twin like you know
looking at someone who looks exactly
like you but who gets more power than
you and more privilege just because he
exited the womb a minute before you did
is patently absurd so yeah I think that
Thailand would feel jealous of Lord
Jason
um
and I wonder if there's like similar
Dynamics with Eric and Eric you know I
wonder who is the elder who is the elder
brother between Eric and
Eric I wonder if Eric is the rebellious
Second Son and it was Eric who went off
to rhaenyra whereas the Elder more sort
of arrogant and privileged Eric who
decided to stay with aegon I wonder
Robert says that beesbury is master of
coin not the Lannister ah yes that's
true Robert thank you for correcting me
I I think I mistakenly said that
Thailand was the master of coin but at
this point Thailand is the master of
ships
uh but we're gonna need a new master of
coin because the master of coin uh Lyman
beesberry B's in the chat buzz buzz uh
is dead so we're gonna need a new master
of coin uh meanwhile Jasper Wilde iron
Rod is the master of laws and all while
is the grand maester
um and Otto was handed the king and
Thailand is master of ships and Harold
westerling the Lord commander of the
kingsguard has left because he thinks
that the greens are wrong in rejecting
rhaenyra and supporting aegon
um so they're gonna need a new Lord
Commander as well I think Allison said
that she wants Kristen to be the new
Lord commander of the king's God
which is a pretty bold move you know
making uh Kristen the Lord commander of
the kingsguard given that he has a
history of the [ __ ] murking people in
Cold Blood Lyman and Joffrey lawnmuth
and all these people so uh
uh yeah he's not exactly unbiased and
impartial bloody Kristen father paprika
says am I Daft or does mazaria equals
Melisandre make sense there are
similarities between mazaria and
Melisandre like they both come from the
East they both seem to have been slaves
they both have knowledge of things uh
they both have a sort of higher moral
purpose
and Melisandre is very old Melisandre is
like magically hundreds of years old and
is able to change her appearance like
Melisandre makes herself appear Young
when she's actually very old so no you
are not Daft father paprika
um it is technically possible that
mazaria is secretly Melisandre wearing a
magical glamor to hide her identity
um I don't think she is the same person
because like Melisandre is very much a
red Priestess who's motivated by wanting
to stop the white walkers but I guess
maybe at this point in her Arc
Melisandre has not discovered the power
of her law
but I mean she must be magical already
so yeah like I mean there's nothing in
the books to suggest that mazari is
Melisandre I think the real reason why
these characters are similar is because
George Martin constantly uses similar
character archetypes over and over
um
but yeah you're not crazy you're not
crazy I'll note that in the books
mazaria is described as an older woman
an old woman a very pale old woman from
lease
um
the White Worm That's Why They Call Her
the White Worm she's very pale and um
yeah and I don't know what that accent
is supposed to be
uh no spoilers uh thank you laslin and
Dave who says rhaenys is the best person
right moral loyal emotionally stable
everything right if she was Queen
instead of viserys yeah I mean rainey's
seems smarter than most of these
characters and rainy seems less biased
than most of these characters like she's
constantly telling callers like hey like
stop getting people killed for the sake
of your political ambition like rhaenys
is is willing to just [ __ ] like chill
and protect human life which is
something that almost every other
character seems incapable of doing
and so yeah I think I think that rainy's
would make a better ruler than most of
these characters she does seem more wise
I mean I think that part of the reason
why rhaenys is so wise is because she
has lived a long time and has seen all
the [ __ ] that other people get up to
like she has learned from her
experiences and from the bitter taste of
being rejected from the throne like if
rhaenys was given the throne at the
Harren Hall Council maybe she would not
have been so wise and restrained like
when she was younger when she because
remember that was like 30 years ago so
young rainies I you know young rhaenys
was not the same person as old rainies
like young rhaenys was a more you know
gung-ho Dragon Rider you know Rebel
Without a Cause you know I I think that
if she got the throne at that time she
may not necessarily have been as wise as
rainius is now but um yeah I really
enjoyed this conversation between
rhaenys and Allison where rhaenys is
sort of conferring her wisdom and saying
like hey if you let these warmongering
men control the situation there's gonna
be war and disaster so we need to take
action to steer the course of events
towards peace and I think that given
rainisa's experience and wisdom I think
that makes sense and I'm really glad
that that was like this really important
motivating spark behind Allison
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Mr
itani muli bees in the chat John says
that definitely wasn't the first time
that transaction took place between
Alison and Laris yeah I I want yeah yeah
um feat for um
feat for information yeah I mean it
could be worse but it could really be a
whole lot better too couldn't it um yeah
it was quite gross
um I hope it doesn't escalate
I I hope that yeah Alison has Alison is
comfortable with it she doesn't seem it
though Nat says lots of parallels with
season one of Game of Thrones with the
death of Ned Stark versus viserys Noble
honorable sympathetic men die and then
War breaks out yeah there there are
similarities I mean there are also a lot
of similarities between
um viserys and Robert Baratheon like
especially in the books
um like viserys in the books comes off
as more of just a sort of a party boy
who doesn't want to think about the
politics and sort of drinks himself to
death and then leaves a political
[ __ ] for everyone else to deal
with it's more hot day that made viserys
into a well-intentioned self-sacrificing
good father
um and I think they did a great job of
it
44 says what do you think happened to
Sir Harold westerling yeah I mean he he
walks out of the room and says I'm I'm
not going to participate in this until
there's a king for me to serve because
I'm in on the King's Guard and he
reminded me a lot of Barris and sell me
so maybe he'll he'll defect to rhaenyra
or or maybe he's just gonna [ __ ]
retire and yeah it is different because
Harold westerling is dead at this point
in the books so be interesting to see
how that turns out Kevin says why is it
that all three of viserys's children and
aegon's unclaimed children have silver
hair but none of rhaenyra's kids do with
non-targaryens
um well as viserys says in a previous
episode uh nature is a thing of Wonders
and Mysteries
I don't know man do you want me to Break
Out the punnet Squares I don't think
there's necessarily like hard and fast
rules with genetics in this world like
there is the thing with the baratheons
where the seed is strong so lagrinis has
black hair in the books because she's
the daughter of Jocelyn Baratheon
um but yeah like Rainier's kids have
dark hair that they got from their
father Harwin sometimes targaryens have
dark hair like like dayron the drunkard
and and dayron and a bunch of characters
in the books who are Targaryen have dark
hair
um nature does all sorts of stuff DNA is
a trip
um and that that has been a plot point
before like you know
dayron Targaryen we talked about the
blackfyre rebellions before part of the
reason why some people rebelled against
uh daeron is because he had dark air and
they're like well you're not a Targaryen
if you've got dark hair which is absurd
because you know genetics happens but um
that is an issue and it's so it is
really significant that aegon II son of
Alison and viserys he has that blonde
hair he looks like a Targaryen and so
that superficial appearance is really
important
um and so Rainier is kids with Daemon
aegon and viserys their blonde hair that
makes them really significant and Jahira
and joharis the children of Helena and
aegon they have blonde hair and that's
really significant whereas Jace Luke and
Joff have a disadvantage in that respect
thanks for and yeah well yeah Jon Snow
is another example yeah because Jon Snow
um at least in the show is the son of
rhaegar Targaryen and lyanna Stark
um so John is a Targaryen or at least a
Targaryen bastard whereas he has dark
hair so you know it is possible
it is possible but I mean there's also
that question of like you know do you
have the like you know do you have
Targaryen blonde hair but also do you
have Targaryen dragon writing jeans
and one of the issues in the books is
that when Jace Luke and Joff were born
and they had like Harwin Strong's dark
features people were like well there's
no way that Jace Luke and Joff are going
to be Dragon Riders because clearly
they're not true targaryens but despite
that Jace Luke and Joff or Jason Luke do
claim dragons
um so you don't need the blonde hair to
be a Targaryen Dragon Rider
but it helps it probably helps
um and and it is interesting like you
know the intermarriage of the valerians
and the targaryens and the dragon riding
genes there as well because like Rayna
Targaryen doesn't have a dragon her
Dragon hasn't hatched whereas Baylor did
so it's like having the jeans for the
hair having the jeans for the dragon
riding and you know how you're perceived
in terms of your political legitimacy I
always really enjoy the way this series
intermingles like you know political
real politic issues of political
legitimacy
with
um magic and dragons and then with the
human drama and it's all such a
wonderfully heady mix
thanks for the Super Chat from Fabian
who says is it just me or do all the
dragon eggs look the same they are
different colors at least
um I think they have made some effort to
make the dragon eggs look different like
this one is orange and this one is Mossy
um looks like it's got slimed at the
Kids Choice Awards
um this one is darker sort of a dark
green I think that the the color of the
eggs corresponds to the color of the
Dragon
like in Game of Thrones
um the dragon eggs like daenerys's
dragon eggs
um correspond to the color of the
Dragons
um because uh rhaegal is green and
viserion is white and dragon is black in
the books and the color of the egg
corresponds to the color of the Dragon
which is cute they've even got scales
and everything
um
and you know there's the whole issue of
like dragon egg petrification like
sometimes dragon eggs hatch sometimes
they don't hatch and if they don't hatch
they fossilize and they turn to Stone
over time although Daenerys dragon eggs
did eventually hatch even though they
were super old
um and that it is possible by the way uh
that dreamfire the dragon of Helena the
eggs laid by dream fire might be
daenerys's dragon eggs 170 years later
um possibly because there were some eggs
that were stolen by Alyssa farman and
she sold them to a pentoshi cheese manga
or she sold them to the Sea Lord of
braavos
um and it's hinted that those dragon
eggs may have later ended up being
daenerys's dragon eggs and it is
possible that the eggs were laid by
dream fire so the point is that uh
Helena targaryen's Dragon might be the
mother of Daenerys targaryen's dragons
which is Kawaii
thanks for the Super Chat from
fac jbf who says that Laris and
suspicious fires equals summer Hall oh
there's a fun Theory
because in the Game of Thrones books one
of the biggest mysteries in the whole
series is the destruction of Summer Hall
and um this was where some important
characters died and it was this just
horrible emotional tragedy that that
weakened the targaryens uh and resulted
in the deaths of some beloved characters
um and it's the reason why rhaegar is an
emo it's the reason why rhaegar was a
sad boy because he was born at this
moment of tragedy and death
um and so yeah he like hung out at the
ruins of Summer Hall and sung sad songs
and was just a just an absolute emo
heartthrob and got real into his
feelings and that's why that sort of
eventually led to him running off with
lyanna and fathering Jon Snow um but the
point is that summerhall was this very
mysterious suspicious fire no one knows
what caused the fire so maybe our
favorite foot loving fire fire bug
Laris Firefly is strong uh sparked this
fire just as he starts the fire to try
and kill mazaria in this episode
um that I I like the theory uh and of
course you say well you know
um the fact like how how is it that
Larissa is still alive because Summer
Hall happens like a hundred years later
well there are some vague hints or
rather wild speculation that Laris might
be a a green Seer who can connect with
the magic of the old gods and like our
friend bloodraven
uh who is the three-eyed Crow who trains
Bran Stark in the ways of the old gods
um like bloodraven bloodraven extends
his life for 100 Years by connecting in
with the weirwoods and like becoming one
with the with the hive mind of the old
gods and the children of the forest
um and that allows him to live for a
very long time and to continue to
um to continue to influence events from
afar so uh maybe Lawrence Strong after
his Shenanigans in House of the Dragon
goes and plugs into the wheelwood net
and survives for long enough to continue
meddling
um and causes summer Hall
and you know maybe he did that on the
Isle of faces because the Isle of faces
is the most significant uh sacred holy
site of the old gods in the South and it
just happens to be literally next door
to I mean not literally but right real
close to Laris Strong's house harrenhal
so you you you're not even being crazy
[ __ ] you're not Daft I love it
um why would Laris do it I'm not sure
um but you know maybe Laris is still
there on the Isle of faces in the main
Game of Thrones series I mean maybe
Laris is one of the green Sears who we
see with bloodraven in bloodraven's cave
um because you know bloodraven is not
the only green seer
um in the in the cave like we see a
bunch of other green seers and most of
them seem to be Children of the forest
but like there's a bunch of people who
are like creepily wired into the Matrix
um and
maybe Lara strong is one of them you
know maybe Lara strong is like subsumed
into the hive mind and it sort of makes
sense with you know Lara strong being a
club foot you know being someone who
can't walk around much that's very
similar to bran right because part of
why bran Embraces the magical power of
the old gods is because he can't get
power and he can't get freedom because
of the limitations of his physical body
so he instead Embraces his psychic
immaterial power so maybe Laris would do
the same and you know Laris is a voyeur
um or you know he loves looking at feet
if Laris plugged into the weirwood
network and was therefore able to watch
and surveil the entire world at all
times larus could look at all the feet
he wants if he was plugged into the
All-Seeing weirwood net so um yeah that
was your tinfoil Corner sponsored by
fact jbf thanks for the Super Chat
uh thank you for the Super Chat from
Spirits who says the Beast below the
boards is the Red Queen yeah we've had a
couple of people say that I agree it's a
great idea that melly's bursting up from
the floor might be what Helena was
talking about with the Beast below the
boards
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Smythe
we all right we've got a lot of larys
did Samuel agreement thanks uh Daewoo
who says no man is so accursed as the
kin Slayer and yeah that that's a good
point Daewoo that in the previous
episode we you know we had this big
emphasis on rainey's being traumatized
by all of the death in her life like
both of her children Lena and Lenor have
died or she thinks Lenore is dead and
her husband Carlos is on his deathbed
and she's you know really horrified by
all of this death
um and so it makes perfect sense that
you know she would not want to go out
and murder people when she's in this
mindset of being so hurt
um by all of the death yeah I think
that's a great point
Matthew says how long does aegon remain
controllable when he realizes that
crowds of screaming people will give him
love that he feels like he never got
from his parents great question Matthew
um because you know up until now it
seemed as though aegon might be
controllable yeah like if aegon just
doesn't care about politics yeah we
could totally see him being just
controlled by
um
Otto and Alison in the same way that
like you know Joffrey
uh was this horrible person who liked
hurting people and who you know Cersei
and Tywin attempted to control but you
know the Cersei and Tywin often had
difficulty controlling Joffrey there's
lots of similarities between
Otto and Tywin and aegon and Joffrey and
uh Cersei and Allison lots of
similarities there so you know will will
they be able to control aegon or will he
be a giant [ __ ] problem like Joffrey
was I think that's a great question and
you know aegon is not someone who
practices a lot of restraint is he like
you know he goes to the fighting pits he
fathers bastard children
um he's actually assaults people so
aegon is not someone who's going to use
power with wisdom and restraint like I
mean aegon says I'm not qualified don't
make me King I'll be a bad King so you
know he he was warning them
and uh yeah I think they're about to
find out just how bad a king can be I
thought it was interesting that they
called viserys viserys the peaceful like
kings often get epithets epithets
epithets
um words to describe what they were like
like aegon was the Conqueror maegor was
the cruel aegon IV was the Unworthy
aerys was the Mad King jaharis was the
conciliator and viserys is apparently
the peaceful
I wonder what what kind of King aegon
will be if he manages to cling on to his
new Throne what will his epithet be what
will rhaenyra's epithet be if she gets
the throne
um be cool to find out I I did hate bran
the broken
like like in Game of Thrones season
eight like calling bran the broken is
such a [ __ ] Downer as like the climax
of the series and it's so sort of
insulting to bran like it's such a [ __ ]
to call him the broken like are you
serious like what what what does that
mean to mean thematically what what a
sad wet fart to end the most popular TV
show of the last decade
anyway
um
viserys the Lego builder in the chat
aegon the drunk
larus the toe
there you go on the vicious aegon the
nightmare brand the paste eater Rainier
the entitled
aegon the mama's boy lots of good
brainstorming going on in the live chat
viserys the Crusty Dusty oh boy
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Alexander who says is Helena supposed to
be autistic she has traits yeah I mean
I'm not going to try to diagnose a
fictional character
um I'm not gonna crack out the DSM
um but it was interesting to see in the
previous episode when Daemon killed
vemond uh and Helena's reaction was to
put her hands over her ears
um and I have heard that like feeling
overwhelmed by sounds and stimulus
um is a symptom of like autism spectrum
disorder and yeah social difficulties
and yeah I'm not gonna I'm not gonna try
and diagnose her but yeah like I think
that there may be some
um I think that might be what's going on
here I mean it's like um Stannis like a
lot of people speculate that Stannis
Baratheon is um
Autistic or Asperger's or whatever
because Stannis also has like social
difficulties and he has a great
adherence to rules and like following
procedures
um
and a lot of people love Stannis for
that and I think that a lot of people
love Helena for the way that she is as
well and I think that that's lovely but
I mean they also at the same time are
playing into the like autistic Savant
Trope right
like I think that a lot of fantasy
stories fall into this like if you are a
neurotypical if you are neural
neurodivergent then you are psychic and
it is kind of insulting that it's like
if you are different or if you are
disabled then you must have superpowers
and that's what that's what redeems you
and that's a bit [ __ ] up because like
people in the real world who are
disabled usually don't have psychic
powers so it's kind of like you know are
you saying that disabled people or
neurotypical a neurotypical people are
only worthy if they have superpowers
like that's kind of a messed up message
but you know I'm not gonna soapbox thank
you for the Super Chat from Maria who
says I was expecting this episode to be
much more action-packed but it seems
like they're saving everything the for
the finale
yeah so you know traditionally in Game
of Thrones uh episode 9 was often the
battle episode like the Blackwater
episode or the Cersei well no that was
in episode 10 but yeah often episode 9
is is the big battle action sequence but
you know House of the Dragon season one
is a very different Beast to Game of
Thrones in a lot of ways so I we should
not always expect it to follow that same
structure and I think what they're doing
here
is that episode 9 is all about the
greens all about Alison and Otto and
aegon whereas the finale next week is
going to be about the blacks which is
rhaenyra and her family
um which is a really interesting way to
do it I think they're doing it almost
like a two-part finale like in instead
of doing one big finale episode they're
doing two sides of one finale split into
two halves which I think is really
interesting from the whole sort of like
perspective angle you know like two
different sides of History like this is
the green perspective and then we're
gonna get the black perspective and it's
going to be like two different views of
the same situation so I I think that
that's an interesting way to do it I
think they've really put some thought
into this guys like I've said it before
but my God it just really feels like
this show has been written by people who
care about the story and have thought
about it and are drawing from what's
good in the books which is what you
should expect effect but it didn't
always feel like what we got in the
later seasons of Game of Thrones so I'm
I've really been pleasantly surprised by
this show so far Matt says do targaryens
not have their own Army are they only
from what Lords swear to them
um yeah that's an interesting question
I'm not as expert on some of the
military matters of this series as some
people are
um but yeah I don't think there's any
mention of like a Targaryen standing
army I think the closest thing is that
there are Lords in the crown lands
and the crown lands
um I mean you know the valerions and the
celtagars and the and the stokeworth and
rosby and like all maidenpool or all of
these like you know towns
um and places around King's Landing they
are Lords and houses that are sworn
directly to House Targaryen like they
are not in the Seven Kingdoms they are
in the crown lands so I think the
closest thing to a Targaryen Army is the
um is the armies of these Petty Lords
who are sworn to the targaryens like in
theory the targaryens can just holler
and all these Lords will bring their
armies right there ready to go
um I mean there's also the city watch of
King's Landing the gold cloaks who we
saw Daemon leading earlier on and the
gold cloaks are a sort of a private Army
in King's Landing owned by the
targaryens uh but of course you know the
loyalties of all of those
um factions are not Beyond question I
mean it's like I think in this episode
uh someone said like you know some of
the gold cloaks commanders are loyal to
us the greens but some of these gold
clerk commanders uh are still loyal to
Daemon so that's an issue that has
already been discussed is like you know
when we get to the pointy end who will
the gold cloaks support
um so yeah uh I think that these are
some of the conversations that Thailand
and Jasper and Otto have been having
like who can we rely on who are our
allies who can we draw on
um and yeah so the gold cloaks and the
crownlands Lords are some of the most
immediately available soldiers here
thanks for the Super Chat from
oh well Matt also asks do you have an
all-time favorite character from the
books or shows I like a lot of the minor
characters like aloras slash Sorella is
really fun
um in terms of main characters I think
Tyrion is the most
richly detailed character and we've got
a video called the real Tyrion Lannister
that goes deep into that
um
and I've also got some love for uh Lord
Hightower in the main books who just
hangs out in the high tower reading
Magic books all day with his mad maid
almond high tower I think he seems cool
thanks for the Super Chat from Adam who
says yeah we've we've talked about
rainey's I'm not going to re-answer the
same question a million times
um
tabuly points out that you know rainey's
bursting out with her dragon is also
like a you know it's a defiant badass
Act of saying like yeah you tried to
lock me up you tried to imprison me in
my Chambers so I'm gonna burst the [ __ ]
out and defy your control yeah that's
absolutely an angle there
yeah Leighton High Tower that's right
Leighton High Tower was who I was
talking about
um thanks for the Super Chat from Jedi
stooge who says that Alison was more
Brave than aegon I I don't think aegon
is suddenly going to become a more Brave
and heroic person I think aegon has
always taken the path of least
resistance he always has just taken like
the easiest path towards immediate
gratification and that's why he drinks
and does sexual
Misadventures and goes to child pit
fights I think that aegon is not
suddenly going to become a hard-working
Noble person
um but it will be fascinating to see how
the crown changes him because crowns do
change uh the the Kings who wear them in
Game of Thrones so it'll be interesting
to see that
thanks for the Super Chat from Andrew
who says rhaenys must have overheard
Alison to talking to Otto reluctance to
murder is not weakness yeah yeah I think
that rainy showed restraint by not
murdering all those people
yeah that's a good point Jess says amond
thinks that he's next in the line to the
throne after aegon to his two sons
jeharis and maelor not count
yeah so
Amon seems to think that he deserves the
throne and he sees himself as aegon's
Heir despite the fact that aegon has two
children jehera and joharis and yeah by
the laws of inheritance
um aegon's Heir is jiharies he's his
eldest male
um I mean but you know as we saw with
Daemon you know there are often various
opinions about inheritance does an uncle
come before a daughter does a cousin
come before a nephew there's all sorts
of complicated interpretations and I
mean aemond like the succession has has
been weird like it's been consistently
inconsistent ever since aegon the
Conqueror
um because you know maegor stole the
throne from a niece's child and then you
know jiharis skipped rainis and gave it
to Balon and then viserys got it which
sets a male precedent but then rhaenero
was meant to have it which sets a female
precedent so like the whole inheritance
thing is has been wibbly wobbly
for years so you know it's not
surprising that Amon thinks that he can
get the throne but yeah you're right
Jess that in theory Joe Harris or johera
should be aegon's Heir not aemond but
you know if you think that's going to
stop amond
we might have another thing coming
Salif says doesn't amond love his
brother
I mean amond was bullied by aegon like
remember when amond got the pink dread
um in episode episode
seven
um
he he was being bullied by aegon along
with um the other kids yeah episode six
sorry
um
on had a [ __ ] time from aegon and you
know we we saw like he
he dislikes aegon for you know not
taking anything seriously and just
drinking and hitting on girls whereas
aemon sees himself as like a more
rightful dutiful kid and there's also an
element of what seems like a hint of
envy that that aegon marries Helena
whereas aemon said I would have
happily married Helena so some people
are thinking that well maybe amond has a
crush on Helena who is his sister but
you know Targaryen incest
um and maybe amond wants Helena and it
wouldn't be the first time targaryens
have fought over their sister so yeah
there may be some
um incestuous romantic rivalry stuff
going on some people have wildly
speculated that maybe Helena's children
are actually aemon's children
because you know aegon has been going
off and you know having sex with people
that the child pit fighting Zone and
whatever
um and Helena says that Amon Helena says
that aegon ignores her except for when
he's drunk and that sounds a bit like uh
Robert baratheon's relationship with
Cersei where Cersei says that Robert
never came and had sex with me except
for when he was drunk and when Robert
was wasted I just finished him off with
my hands and so he never got me pregnant
meanwhile Cersei was actually having her
children with Jamie and we could
speculate that maybe something similar
is happening with aegon and Helena like
maybe aegon is not impregnating Helena
because he's drunk and she's avoiding it
and maybe the actual person getting
Helena pregnant is her brother amond
there's a lot of there's a lot of incest
but this is the sort of stuff that goes
on in these books and uh yeah it is it
is not there's no proof but it is
interesting speculation that Helena's
children may actually be aemons and it
introduces you know that would mean that
those children are bastards just like
Rainier's Sons Jace Luke and Joff are
bastards and that would create a whole
other microcosm of uh corruption and
insanity and illegitimacy on the green
side of the equation so that's an
interesting Theory
uh Paul yeah good point Fredo let's do a
poll do you guys who do you support
um
rhaenyra
and team black or Alison and aegon and
and
Team Green
there is now a poll in the live stream
you can vote who you support Rainier and
Alison uh Rainier versus Alison I think
in the pre I think last week we did a
poll it was like 87 in support of
Rainier I think so let's see what the
numbers are this time I mean this time
was all focused on Alison's side so you
know you'd think that this might make us
more sympathetic to Alison I think
Allison herself was pretty sympathetic
because she was very clear about not
wanting to murder people this episode
and she was talking about the greater
good but you know she also fundamentally
was crowning aegon on the false belief
that viserys wanted aegon to be king and
uh you know we saw more of how evil
aegon is with his child pit fight and
his bastard children who were living in
squalor there
um and that is who Alison is supporting
meanwhile Rainier is not even aware of
everything that's going on right now I
mean rhaenyra I mean last episode made
Rainier look good because Rainier was
the one who was offering an olive branch
to Alison and who was trying to
reconcile
currently the numbers say 88 support
Rainier and 12 support Alison that's
with uh 2 000 votes in so yeah still
overwhelming support for rain era not
for Allison's pretty similar numbers
uh some people in the live chat saying
that you know you can't even really
evaluate Team Green as a whole like
because
Otto and Alison are now against each
other in a lot of ways like they they
were butting heads and they wanted to do
things differently so yeah like Team
Green is not a monolith and neither is
team black so yeah it's not as simple as
one side or the other
thanks for the Super Chat from solar who
says would it be fair to say that
rhaenys was wearing her red and black
armor under her cloak that whole morning
yeah well she did do a pretty quick
wardrobe change to get into that armor
on her Dragon didn't she
um yeah pretty impressive stuff maybe
she had you know Velcro clothes that she
could rip off um yeah I don't know
um I'm glad she had the armor though
and you know the yeah the red and black
colors those are like Targaryen colors
and they're also more associated with
rain era because rhaenyra is the
Targaryen versus Allison the green
Hightower so you know she didn't kill
the greens but she was wearing the she
was wearing Rainier as colors though
um thanks for the Super Chat from sb10
who says do the other crowns have names
like aegons yeah so there is there is
history to these crowns um the crown
that we saw viserys wearing and the
crown that we saw in this episode
um was originally Harris's Crown uh and
that Crown at least in the books was
given to joharis by the faith of the
seven
um and in the books it's described as
being gold with a bunch of like jewels
and it's got like the the seven gods on
it
um in Hot D it's got like the Tully
sigil and like all of the great houses
sigils on it so it's a change from the
books but it emphasizes like the
conciliator bringing together and
uniting all of the great houses of the
realm together
um which I think is also nice and
appropriate for J Harris and so you know
it emphasizes how viserys continued
jeheris's Legacy as a unifier and as a
peacemaker
and you know viserys fumbled that Legacy
and viserys ultimately left the realm
more divided but that's what the crown
represents whereas the crown of aegon
the Conqueror is made of Valyrian steel
with rubies it's like blood and fire
it's Valyrian it's war-like so you know
aegon's Crown has has very different
symbolism behind it
um and we may we might we may ask the
question of if aegon is wearing uh
aegon's Crown then what happens to
viserys and jeheris's Crown
uh Jew likes Allison and says I like the
imagery of a room full of plotting
sharp-witted plotters the old person who
they thought wasn't worth keeping in the
loop defied them yeah I mean that's a
good point like like Lyman B's Brie was
not aware of Thailand and Jasper and
otters plotting like they must have
deliberately not included him like there
was an interesting line where where the
men said to Allison oh you know we we
didn't tell you about our plans because
we didn't want to Sully you you know oh
you're only a woman there's no need for
you to know these things it's like in
the books in the books in the books Lara
strong is at this meeting and Lara says
Hey folks let's do a Blood Oath and they
all cut their hands and and hold their
hands together to swear a secret Bond of
Brotherhood to support aegon and make
aegon king
um but Alison was not included in the
boy's Blood Oath because
she's a woman on account of her sex she
was not included in In The Blood Oath um
which you know it doesn't sound very
very covert safe anyway but but yeah
like Alison being excluded on the basis
of agenda is something that the books
have always been interested in going
back to you know Cersei Etc
um
it's interesting that Orwell is still
you know quietly present
um Orwell was not stupid enough to stand
up and defy the greens and get killed
like Lyman was like I think that that
all while quietly said to Lyman like hey
like her shop or they're gonna kill you
so I wonder what Orwell's role is going
to be going ahead because like even in
the previous episode we saw that Orwell
was like not super on board
um stealing drift Mark for vemond
instead of Luke
um I wonder if Orwell might have
valerion Heritage I wonder where he's
from
um because that's another change from
the books or while being black
um but yeah Orwell is like quietly like
not okay with what's going on with the
greens and I wonder if he's going to
continue to go along with him or I
wonder if he's going to defy them
there's a whole storyline in the books
about like who gets to be the next Grand
maester and like rhaenyra supports one
maester and Allison supports another
maester and it's this whole other sort
of like little subplot that happened
earlier that they didn't include in the
show
uh bill says who else is curious about
how sir Laris strong broached the feet
of voyeurism request to Alison I I don't
want to know personally but yes like
it's like how do you how do you bring it
up
how do you how do you bring it up to the
queen that hey I'd really love to see
your feet and also I have secret
information
maybe maybe that's exactly how larus
asked uh yeah we talked about the
succession Domi says during viserys's
last moments he's actually seeing the
mother who he mistakes for Emma oh
you're saying that he actually saw the
the god of the faith of the seven in the
Visage of the mother and he sort of
thought that it was Emma but it wasn't
the faith of the seven finally actually
wielding some magical influence in this
world
maybe maybe someone was entering his
dreams people with glass candles can
enter each other's minds there's lots of
you know hints of magic being able to
manipulate people's minds in this world
and you know this should be a magical
time because magic is tied to dragons
and there are lots of dragons around at
the moment so you'd think that there
should be all sorts of sorcery afoot I
do wonder if we're gonna see more magic
in the story there's not a lot of magic
in the books around this time but you
know we'll see if there's any going on
quietly in the show
uh kale feels insulted by the larys
scene thank you William thank you renin
who says uh Eric
was Disturbed
yeah Eric and Eric sort of went back and
forth I was not always keeping track of
which one was Eric and which one was
Eric personally all right uh we're going
to wrap up this live stream shortly uh
we've been talking for two and a half
hours
um so I'm gonna quickly answer as many
of your super chats as I can I apologize
if I don't get to all of them and then
we're going to have a brief look at the
on the next episode preview trailer
um are there any other things that I
wanted to talk about I thought it was
funny how Thailand was like totally
failing to read the room when he uh like
walked in and said all right what what
why'd you drag me out of bed for what
what why couldn't this wait an hour why
have we got to have a meeting in the
middle of the night and he just totally
failed to read the room and failed to
see how you know Otto and Alison and
Kristen are looking stoney-faced because
the King has just died and Thailand's
just totally failed and yeah again like
I think Thailand has become much more of
a douche than he used to be
um
and you know also there was that whole
thing with Talia like Allison's maid and
you know Talia lit those candles in that
window to indicate to mazaria that the
king is dead
um so just as Odo and the men have been
planning for ages like what to do when
viserys dies uh Talia and mazaria have
also been planning all along yeah in the
books by the way uh mushroom suggests
that Allison poisoned viserys which is
clearly not true in Hot D but uh well I
mean maybe all that milk of the poppy
was bad for him actually because in the
books it seems as though
um Littlefinger is deliberately drugging
sweet Robin John Robert Aaron uh in
order to make him die more quickly
um and so maybe like Otto was sort of
getting the maesters to like really dose
viserys up with milk of the poppy maybe
Otto wanted viserys to die sooner even
if Allison maybe didn't
um
yeah I liked mazaria protecting kids
yeah I like that there was a line where
someone said that aegon is fleeing what
other men die seeking like aegon was
literally trying to run away from being
the king
um and Otto says I think it was Otto who
said that like oh you're fleeing what
other men die seeking like some people
want the throne so much they'll die for
it and you're running away from it and
it's like from aegon's perspective well
duh you know he's running away from it
because people die for this Throne he
doesn't want to die for this Throne like
it's so funny that in some ways aegon is
the most despicable evil character
because he hurts other people and has no
interest in other people's feelings but
aegon is also the guy who's saying some
truths uh which is that the throne is
terrible and no one should want it and
he is unqualified you know
um so yeah uh Jess points out aegon's
Golden Dragon sigil yeah we we did get a
glimpse of the golden dragon because one
of the issues
um well you know we won't spoil anything
but um heraldry is important how do you
identify the different factions and it
looks like aegon is opting for a golden
dragon as his personal sigil which is
something that people do sometimes they
take on a personal heraldry to identify
themselves and so aegon is the golden
dragon and that's because he has the
Golden Dragon Sunfire
Sunfire the golden uh is aegon's dragon
and it's said to be the most beautiful
dragon in the world of all time so their
aegon is riding Sunfire with his Golden
Dragon heraldry and this is artwork by
Rudolph Hema which I think is really
lovely
uh deeb says that a lot of the Nobles
are wearing these low hanging chains on
their clothing yeah yeah there's been a
lot of that like Alison has been wearing
some of those prominently a lot of
people with some heavy golden necklaces
which I'm enjoying but yeah Otto also is
wearing this chain it all like I think
that in Otto's case it sort of evokes
the maesters chain and hints of the
connection between the high towers and
the misters who were based in Old Town
um but I think you know with Alison to
the chain sometimes suggests Allison's
like restraint like Alison feels so
restricted by rules and expectations and
courtesy and pressures and gender and
religion so she she feels chained so
yeah I think there's lots of interesting
symbolism with the chains for sure
um
radnage says that Laris strong has a
weakness for feet a fetus
Eddie asks about the Beast under the
boards I think that you know without
spoiling anything like it definitely
evokes the secret passages the spies all
of the agents inside the red keep
um and it may connect to melis bursting
through the ground but I think we will
learn more about the Beast beneath the
boards
wambulance says it's wild that rhaenys
didn't kill Team Green yeah look she
they don't know the future she doesn't
want to be a murderer and she and
rhaenys just had this conversation with
Alison rhaenys's trusting Allison to do
the right thing you know like if rainy's
hadn't had this conversation with Alison
maybe she would have barbecued the
greens but you know that they had a real
connection here and and I think that
rhaenys is trusting Allison and kind of
threatening Alison to do the right thing
and to not let this spiral out of
control and we will see how that goes
down
um andrex says that every Targaryen
bastard is a potential Dragon Rider is
it not
yes that's a great point on DirectX
because yeah like we saw that aegon has
this uh bastard child in the rat pits
where where the hell was that bastard
um there was this little blonde kid and
if that is the bastard child of aegon
Targaryen then that child might be a
potential Dragon Rider and we do have a
bunch of dragons uh lying around without
Riders like sea smoke and Verma Thor and
Silverwing and and others
um so yes uh just as you know they're
trying to like just as Daemon is
hoarding dragon eggs on Dragonstone
we're gonna need writers for those eggs
so so those are all relevant questions
Nick says imagine Varys and Littlefinger
during this ordeal I I feel like
Littlefinger would definitely want to
see Alison's feet I think there's a lot
of similarities between Laris and
Littlefinger for sure
um I think that
I think that
Varys might be a bit smarter about all
of this than than lyrics is but anyway
uh vixero says why isn't the question of
which aegon viserys was talking about
being discussed
um well Alison interpreted viserys's
words as referring to her son aegon but
yeah like it is hilarious that this
entire conflict might not be happening
if viserys was more clear oh well Andy
if the targaryens didn't all name their
children aegon because yeah like just to
be clear aegon the Conqueror
the founder of the Targaryen Dynasty in
Westeros is called aegon uh Amy's the
king aenys had a child called aegon the
uncrowned now uh viserys and Allison to
have a kid called aegon and now rhaegner
and Daemon have a kid called aegon and
there are many more aegons later in the
story so um it's a [ __ ] mess they
need to stop naming their kids aegon
um and yeah it's a bit silly Cole says
isn't a isn't it a bit sexist that
Alison is being antagonized for reacting
similarly to Rainier's bastards as Ned
Stark probably would have yeah there
absolutely are parallels between Alison
and Ned because just like Ned Alison is
standing up and saying hey we should not
let these bastards unlawfully take the
throne that's against the rules we
should not stand for it so yeah like
their abs there is a
um you know Alison is standing up for
the truth in that respect
um I think that Alison one of the
differences though is that you know
Alison is supporting aegon who is a
terrible person and trying to put him on
the throne
um and Alison you know attacked Rainier
with a knife and you know Alison ordered
for Luke's eye to be cut out so you know
there are some very villainous aspects
to Alison's character
um but yeah like I'm sure there's also
like a gendered aspect to it as well and
that's definitely something that the
show is exploring
thanks for the super chats from Arthur
and Dean and Anastasia
who says did Laris stay and talk to Otto
off screen yeah that was an interesting
conversation we'll investigate that
later for the explained video everybody
like And subscribe by the way there's
going to be a shorter edited scripted
video exploring the episode later in the
week
Christopher says Dear mazaria No the
king died when the candle was lit yes
Talia works for mazaria and Talia lit
these candles in order to tell mazaria
that the king is dead it's a little bit
like
um Brienne was watching for the candles
being lit in Winterfell from Sansa in
Game of Thrones
Anon says it's interesting to see the
division in the greens I agree it I
think this internal division between
Allison and Otto is really important and
it makes Alison more virtuous because in
the books it doesn't talk about a
division between Alice and Otto but it's
easy to see how that division might have
been papered over by the historians
um and it definitely makes Alison more
moral to have her oppose
Otto's
um eagerness for war
Thanks James and rhaenys who says why
was rainy still hanging around King's
Landing when everyone else returned to
Dragonstone and driftmark
yeah that's an interesting question
um I mean rainyro was leaving
specifically to take the kids home
because she didn't want Jace Luke and
Jeff to fight with Alison's kids
Rainier's intention was to stay in
King's Landing I mean maybe rainey's
like everyone else had a suspicion that
King viserys was going to die soon and
rhaenys wanted to make sure that the
outcome was good for her family when the
king died so you know I think everyone
was sort of gravitating towards the
throne and rhaenys rainyro was planning
on coming back as well uh thanks for the
uh well yeah and vemond was going to
have a funeral presumably so that's
another good reason to stay there Cole
says yeah we answered that Dylan says do
you think there's significance to the
brothel Madam who recognizes aemond yeah
that was an interesting interaction
wasn't it
um she was sort of saying that yeah like
aegon used to come here but he decided
that our establishment was too fancy for
him so he went to the rat pits instead
and I'd say like yeah she showed some
confidence and some knowledge and some
Poise so I wonder if we might see her
again I don't think we got a name for
her in the subtitles but yeah I really
like how they're sort of fleshing out
this sort of underbelly in King's
Landing and I I hope that we'll see more
of it it's it's it's an interesting sort
of class thing because like we see the
lowest pits of flea bottom and we see
the upscale Street of silk and we see in
the Royal Court and we see the sort of
different kinds of depravity that goes
on at these various levels of society
you know and um
yeah it's going to be cool to see how
that plays out
Jeffrey says how has no one caught on to
Helena's psychic Visions I mean the
saddest part is that viserys was super
obsessed with prophecy and dreams I mean
I guess later in his life viserys had
sort of sworn off the Visions because
his his vision about having a son is
what got Emma killed in a lot of ways um
but it's so sad that viserys never said
hey Helena my daughter you have dragon
dreams that's so cool I used to have
dragon dreams let's be friends let's be
an actual father and daughter uh so yeah
it is so sad that no one listens to
Helena and I wonder if someone ever will
reg says was it dumb for westerling to
draw his sword and do nothing when Cole
drew his I thought it was kind of dumb
that like Kristen like killed Lyman
beesberry and then Harold westling or
maybe before he was like well take off
your cloak coal like you are no longer a
king's God and then Cole just ignored
that and then Harold just walked out so
you know I yeah I I think that Harold
considers Kristen Cole and green and the
entire Green's side to be like no longer
the legitimate kingsguard and that's why
he left
um
maybe the only reason why Harold didn't
like disarm Kristen or kill Kristen was
because Harold felt outnumbered in that
case and you know I really like that you
know part of why Harold is against the
greens is because Harold was the
protector of rhaenyra we got some really
nice moments between Harold and Rainier
like Harold was clearly really fond of
rhaenyra and he was very very aware that
that Rainier was the chosen heir of
viserys and I think Harold respected
viserys as well so you know like it is a
change to have Harold involved in these
events and I think it's a good change
because Harold has like some real
personal reasons to make these decisions
so I I enjoyed Harold's role so far
eight says original Game of Thrones was
too tough to watch for me so I've
enjoyed listening to you discuss it
thanks eight Stephen says I enjoy the
Nuance they gave Otto during the
coronation scene
he was yelling for the doors to open
yeah that was kind of curious like when
rainy sinner Dragon were in the dragon
pit and Otto was shouting for the doors
to open which I guess was Otto saying
like let's let the dragon out
you don't want you don't want a dragon
feeling trapped in a room with you or
you're gonna die so maybe that's what
was going on there but um yeah Auto I
mean Auto as ever seemed to be the more
practical person in that situation he
was trying to solve the problem and uh
he couldn't fight the dragon so he was
trying to get it out
radnage says how many high bones is
Kristen Cole going to be allowed to kill
in broad daylight is there a three
strike system will beesbury's family
demand retribution good question I mean
one of the issues in the book is
what happened to beesberry because like
like the whole issue here is that the
greens are like locking down the red
keep they're not letting anyone in or
out they don't want anyone to even know
that the king is dead until they're
ready to Crown aegon
um and you know no one none of the
greens are going to want to publicize
the fact that like beesberry was
murdered at the table
um so in the book Fire and Blood because
the book plays with this idea of like
historical accuracy and disputed sources
you know mushroom claims oh they threw
beesbury out a window and another person
says no they slit beesbury's throat but
but one of I think it was either Eustis
or Orwell said uh no no they just locked
beesberry in the dungeons so you know
throughout future events like some of
the the world doesn't know that beesbury
was murdered and the greens aren't going
to tell beesbury's family oh yeah we
murdered your your dad like no so yeah
that's a good questioned ratnage and um
I think for now the greens are trying to
keep it under wraps and you know I mean
that does also raise the whole question
of how did Christian get away with
killing Joffrey lawnmuth and you know
some people have speculated that like
you know maybe Alison and Kristen will
say that oh joffre lawnmuth pulled a
knife and was was trying to attack
rhaenyra or something like they could
just make up some lie like you know I
hate to break it to you but sometimes
people in positions of power do bad
things and cover it up and lie and
sometimes corrupt people remain in
positions of power
um so maybe that's what happened to you
you know like I I for one I'm not
shocked uh Mike says
am I the only one who can't wait until
Mexican Jon Snow gets his
don't know what you're talking about
Mike but I thank you uh beep boop uh
says Melissa's head armor has nine
billion HP yeah I mean how exactly did
melis break through the floor of the
Dragon pit
um and isn't that going to be a problem
that there's a giant hole in the dragon
pit now like man it's gonna be a pain in
the ass to rebuild that what about all
what about all the other dragons down
there like are all the other dragons
down there like looking up through the
hole going like what the [ __ ] is going
on while while peasants rain down on
their heads yeah rhaenys has created a
bit of an architectural issue
redecorating all the feng shui in the
dragon bit is messed up now LOL says
yeah I agree with you Lau John says can
amond use a dragon well considering his
complete lack of depth perception yeah I
mean well aemond doesn't seem to have
any trouble like deflecting Kristen's
flail in in mid-flight despite not
having any depth perception so aemon
seems untroubled by his loss of an eye
um maybe when well well yeah um
I would think yeah I guess that when
you're on a dragon you want to be able
to judge the distance of other objects
in the air and on the ground
um but I think that you know when Dragon
Riders are riding dragons it's a bit of
autopilot like I think the dragon is
making some of the decisions and the
dragon is sort of psychically
interpreting the writers
the intent and going along with it
because like there's no way the dragon
can hear the writer's voice shouting
commands to them through the gusting
winds
um so I think it's more like it doesn't
say so in the books but I think it's
meant to be more of like a psychic
connection similar to skin changing so I
I don't think aemon's lack of an eye is
going to slow Vega down if that's what
you mean uh but you know but but I mean
symbolically amond has a blind spot and
that's something that they were playing
with with viserys in the previous
episode like viserys had a missing eye
and in the dinner scene Allison's family
was on viserys's Blind Side his missing
eye side just like viserys was blind to
the corruption on that side of his
family so I wonder if amond might have a
blind spot metaphorically in the future
Samsung says do you think Alison will
try to pursue the Iron Throne there was
that interesting line where rhaenys
whispered to Alison do you ever picture
yourself on the iron throne and that
that is some real [ __ ] stirring from
rhaenys my god
um will Allison seize the throne for
herself I mean it would be a little bit
like when Cersei seized the throne for
herself in the later seasons of Game of
Thrones
um maybe she would claim like as Cersei
did oh well I mean you know cersei's
kids died but you know maybe Alison
could seize the throne and say that well
I am ruling on the behalf of my son
aegon
um aegon is Young and you know he is um
drunk currently so I'm gonna rule in his
Stead maybe Allison will you know make
herself aegon's hand of the king and
will roll on his behalf so yeah I think
those are interesting questions and it
also ties into like the history of
female rulers in this world like you
know rhaenys wanted to be a female ruler
and didn't get to be so maybe she would
like to see Alison as a female ruler if
not herself
Spirits says someone stole the square
rubies out of aegon's crown yeah I
thought that was interesting
um because aegon's Crown is meant to be
studied studded with these big rubies
but there's sort of these Square spaces
on the crown that look like they should
have rubies in them but they don't so
yeah maybe someone's stolen the rubies
because this is how the crown looks in
the books it clearly has these big
Square rubies whereas the big Square
rubies are missing here so did someone
Nick the rubies I don't know it's a
weird Choice it's a weird choice I don't
know why they're missing
scratty says maybe mazaria doesn't want
to let aegon kill off his bastards in
the flea bottom fighting pits
yeah so I mean mazaria said like I want
you to stop the fighting pits with the
children because that's messed up but I
guess you're saying scratty that maybe
mazaria also has like a political angle
here where she wants to sort of get
control of aegon's bastards uh so that
they don't die in the Pokemon fights
yeah I I think that's a possibility
uh yes Mitchell larys tried to burn the
white worm and we don't know if he
succeeded uh thank you fat moose and
ruler dos who says it took a lot of
willpower to not let my family to not
tell my family that I thought Alison's
feet looked nice ruler does you are very
brave to watch this particular program
with your family James says was rhaenys
really historic as they said Inside the
episode killing oh really heroic killing
hundreds of civilians and then leaving
yeah I agree that it's messed up that
rhaenys murdered all of those innocent
people and I think that that's
consistent with the way it's always been
in this world where even the politicians
who say that they're heroic still think
they're better than innocent people and
even the best kings use the lives of the
people less powerful than themselves to
reinforce their own power so yeah I I
think that's [ __ ] up and I yeah I wish
they sort of I don't know acknowledged
it more like because you know it it
might have been more that point might
have been made better if we saw some of
like the faces of the common people
while they were getting trampled and
killed by the dragon like if we got to
see more of like the I mean I guess
there's sort of a moment here but like
to actually look at the face of the
horror that rhaenys is inflicting on
these people
it seems like that should have happened
you know like and even when she like
burst out the gate like is she stomping
on like a dozen people here you know
like we should have seen the aftermath
of that so yeah I agree like it's messed
up that she did that because she didn't
have to do that I'm pretty sure there's
a back door
uh thanks for the Super Chat from trash
Panda and Justice who says do you think
the white worm could now have a burned
face and later become quite you guys are
coming up with some great tinfoil today
and and I love it yeah there is a very
mysterious character in the books called
quaith
uh who has a lot going on in the books
and some people think that she might be
Alyssa farman and some people think that
she might be Melisandre from the future
some people think that she's Daenerys
from the future some people think that
she's tyrion's time traveling fetus
there's a lot of theories
um and yeah I it would be cool like it
sounds bad to say it would be cool if
mazario was burned by Larissa's fire and
maybe mazaria's personality might change
as a result of this fire uh or maybe
she's just dead I suppose we'll find out
but yeah cool cool theories cool
theories Lowell says Allison's friction
with Otto was unexpected and excellent
she has agency now like never before I
agree thanks Victoria and Nelly
Nelly hopes that aegon will make peace
with the realm hell maybe aegon will
suddenly become a good-hearted
well-intentioned King maybe he'll be the
new jaharis the conciliator
now that he actually wants to be king
maybe he'll actually do well in the
position
who knows that the way he's waving that
sword around makes it look like he um
might want to use it you know maybe
he'll just be eager for conflict
uh did rhaenys say that comment about
Alison wanting the throne to turn Alison
against her father yeah it is really
interesting because on the one hand
rhaenys was saying hey like let's let's
be peaceful here but she was also saying
hey Alison maybe you should take the
throne and you know I I guess what she
means is that you know you could take
the throne and be a benevolent ruler but
I mean realistically Allison trying to
take the throne is likely to cause more
conflict I mean she I mean as a high
tower she's a high tower woman she
couldn't seize the throne in her own
name without pissing off everybody so it
does seem like a uh pretty
um inflammatory thing to say telling
Allison to take the throne
uh yeah we did a Paul bifong says what a
setup for the final episode
um just points out that dog head
targaryens have never actually ended up
on the throne uh what about dayron
Targaryen I think daeron did uh
wealthwolf says that Charles II of
Spain's habsburg's Habsburg jaw was so
bad that he couldn't chew properly his
father with his was his mother's Uncle
so it was a reverse John Danny
uh Ali Riza says who is elephant's
mother yeah we haven't seen Allison's
mother because she died some time ago
but it seems as though Otto
Otto has been very sad ever since his
wife died and I think it's similar to
like you know tywin's wife Joanna died
and I think Tywin became a lot more sort
of hard and cruel and cold and empty
inside after Joanna died a little bit
like you know viserys after Emma died
um but yeah we don't know much about
Alison's mother but I think you know
Alison has struggled with not having a
mother
uh what was the dragon that yeah we're
going to look at the preview shortly
um how do you rate this episode compared
to the rest that this was a weird
episode because they they did a lot of
unexpected things that aren't in the
books and also like you know focusing it
all around the greens was was an
interesting choice that makes it a
different episode to the others and we
got some interesting sort of side
character stuff with Eric and Eric and
Alan Caswell and so yeah it was a very
different episode I think I'm still
figuring out if I like it but
um
I I think it gives us a lot to think
about so we'll process that for the
explained video later in the week
um
thank you existential shrew uh thank you
acinius who says I couldn't get behind
the actor for aegon until he had the
crown on now I think it's a really good
fit yeah I like as I said like I think
this season is basically backstory and I
think in a lot of ways like a lot of the
character arcs in this season are all
about
showing us the character development
that makes the characters into the
person who is described in the books you
know like a lot of these characters are
a little bit different how they appear
in the books but they change throughout
the course of this season until they
become the person that they are
described as in the books I think and I
think aegon is maybe one of those
um a Daemon as well like there really is
some growth with a lot of these
characters it's it's subtle with a lot
of them
you know like Daemon I think has become
a bit more mature
um and a bit more smart and a bit more
self-controlled in a way that only makes
it more dangerous like Daemon has more
to lose now and he's smarter but he's
still like absolutely willing to chop
off a dude's head in the middle of a
conversation so you know whereas aemond
is like the new Young Daemon like amond
is oh well a mod is kind of smart too a
little bit restrained compared to like
aegon who's totally feckless anyway
um
in Fire and Blood gildane Lies by saying
that before viserys died he told his
grandkids a story about how Jairus flew
over the wall to kill wildlings but this
is a lie because dragons can't fly over
the wall yeah you're not wrong pseudo
arasan
um because viserys in Fire and Blood
um they describe his death and it's
different to the books because King
viserys tells some stories to Helena's
children
maegor and he says that ah my grandpa
King jahiras he was such a cool dude and
he fought wildlings Beyond the Wall
um which you know is a made-up story
anyway so you know it it's all fiction
within fiction within fiction
um but there is another thing earlier in
Fire and Blood that describes
that describes Queen alisane the wife of
joharis visiting the wall and trying to
get Silverwing to fly over the wall but
Silverwing refused to fly over the wall
it seems as though Silverwing was like
afraid of the magic of the white walkers
Beyond the Wall
um or maybe the magic of the wall itself
it has magical wards that prevented
Silverwing from Crossing it it's this
very sort of spooky ominous moment
um and uh yeah so that sort of remains a
mystery and it does indeed contradict
viserys's story maybe the maesters made
it up uh thank you Roy we answered that
um all your base yeah I mean there's not
a lot of magic in the books a lot of
talk about magic it would make sense for
there to be magic at this time because
there were dragons and dragons are
connected to Magic but there's not a lot
of magic described in the books either
I am still holding out some hope for
some kind of old gods green Seer Magic
from larus potentially but you know
there are also some characters who have
some magic later in the book so you know
that it might happen it might happen
uh thank you Charles who says they
mentioned Yi T in this episode yeah they
mentioned that they don't know where
aegon is and for all they know he could
be in Yeti
um yiti is the Game of Thrones
equivalent of China it's like this Far
Eastern location
um and it's sort of mythical like it's
so far away in this medieval time that
no one even really quite knows what it's
like
um there's all these like Legends of how
huge and prosperous and amazing UT is at
this time
uh Corliss went there
actually call us has been there
um and that's part of why Carlos is so
famous so it would be cool to hear call
us talk about some of these far distant
places that he's been
um but yeah it is it is also funny that
they slip in a mention of VT in this
show given that there have been reports
that there is a yeti spin-off show in
development from HBO I think it's meant
to be animated and who knows if it'll
actually you know end up being made but
um just as they were talking about name
areas 10 000 ships
in previous episodes and they are
apparently thinking about making a
nymeria show they also are talking about
EET similarly
Yeti phone home indeed
um thanks for the Super Chat from call
me Seeker who says this was a bit of a
bottle episode it might have been the
cheapest episode of the Season since
they didn't have to pay Paddy and Matt
yeah yeah maybe
um
I imagine the show's only going to get
more expensive from here though but yeah
and I think the idea is that next
episode is going to be focused on
rhaenyra and Daemon as its own little
bottle episode yeah
um
despite rhaenys's mass murder it was a
yes moment
could team black fly up and just burn
everyone whenever they want well I mean
remember the conversations that happened
in Game of Thrones
um in the later seasons
when some of daenerys's advises or I
mean Daenerys mostly was saying like hey
um I'm just gonna fly up and burn the
red cave I'm just gonna go right that
right up there and take the throne and
No One's Gonna Stop Me whereas people
like Tyrion were saying maybe maybe
don't attack the city with Dragons
because then lots of people might die I
mean as you know as we saw with raineys
and melis when you play with Dragons uh
there is collateral damage like she
wasn't trying to murder hundreds of
peasants but she did
just just incidentally
um so yeah like Rainier and Daemon and
you know there will be conversations
about this stuff later but like that you
know that I might consider just
attacking King's Landing but there may
also be concerns about collateral damage
very well-grounded concerns about
collateral damage
Carson says is the name aegon cursed
every time an aegon is born War follows
yeah I mean Anisa's son aegon the
uncrowned uh did not do very well and uh
you know aegon IV the Unworthy was uh
pretty cursed aegon the fifth egg was a
lovely boy but he also got
um hard-boiled at summer Hall so um yeah
a lot lot I mean look I mean a lot of
aegons die horribly but a lot of kings
die horribly I mean this is Game of
Thrones a lot of everybody's die
horribly thank you this Justin who says
my girlfriend and I have your videos on
repeat in our house thank you for the
reviews Hi Brie I love you no well done
Justin thank you for the Super Chat
Brandon says we talked about that bill
says Edward we've got some historical
parallels sorry we've got to wrap this
up I've been talking for three hours
um that's a bit of
spoiler just like they are on the
drunken often the nihilistic characters
who who have given up on power are the
only people free to speak the truth even
early Tyrion I agree with you Zerg like
a lot of the characters who are just
like sad and uninvolved are sad and
uninvolved because they see how futile
and [ __ ] up the system is and you know
that you know that that's a feeling that
people have in the real world you know
you see how messed up the world is and
you nope out and maybe yeah in a way
aegon is doing that aegon sees how
[ __ ] up the world is so he's like I
don't want to participate I'm just going
to drink myself to death uh which is not
you know the way he does that is is not
good but uh yeah I agree there's similar
Vibes with dare on the drunken and
Tyrion like Tyrion in in the early
episodes was just living a life of
leisure because he didn't believe in
this unjust world that had rejected him
and spurned him so he just lives a life
of um decadence
aegon is the Chet Hanks of targaryens uh
abidal sir abdiel says this was my
favorite episode
everyone on Team Green is a different
shade of green yeah that's a great way
to say it abdiel the showrunners talk a
lot about like Shades of Gray like these
are all very gray characters but I
suppose we can also talk about it as you
know shades of green and black
uh we talked about that Matt says
rainies bursting through the floor felt
very Game of Thrones season eight
yeah I I think that you know I I sense
that sometimes this show feels obliged
to have a big action violent sequence
that doesn't necessarily always make the
story better like they feel the need for
spectacle even when it isn't necessarily
you know they don't think through the
consequences of it but without spoiling
anything I think that rainey's killing
all those peasants may actually pay off
in a way later on so I think that this
was not completely thoughtless this
particular set piece uh rational orc
says that aegon is like homelander
nolandus says I'm struck by how little
the Starks seem to matter at this point
we see Lannisters and baratheons but no
Starks well keep in mind that like the
north is really far away
um and they're not very economically
important and there aren't all that many
people living in the north so like the
Starks have historically like just not
been very involved in uh Southern
politics I mean in Game of Thrones when
Ned came South it was like a big deal
everyone's like oh stocks coming south
that doesn't happen every day and you
know historically things go badly for
the stocks when they come South like you
know Rickard and Brandon so um so yeah
this it is this is the status quo the
stocks are usually not involved I mean
the stocks are their own you know the
stocks are the first men the stocks are
old gods worshipers like the stocks are
a very different culture it's sort of a
kingdom apart to the rest of the Seven
Kingdoms
uh so yeah the stocks are doing what
they always do which is you know
standing in the snow looking very solemn
skinny says
when Allison called aegon an imbecile I
took it to be in a loving way as if to
say you're my son you're an idiot if you
think I don't love you
yeah I mean I I disagree because in the
previous episode
um aegon said to Amon aegon you're not
my son like Alison almost disowned aegon
in the previous episode I think that you
know Alison does feel some maternal love
for all her children but she also hates
um that her son is a rapist
um so I think there's some complicated
layered feelings there but I I think
that when Alison calls aegon an imbecile
I think it is more of a rejection than
anything positive there
I also thought it was really [ __ ] sad
when Alison came and sat in it next to
Helena and she tried to like Comfort
Helena but then Helena like recoiled
like look at this like Alison tries to
hug Elena and Helena bats her hand as
well away
so I think it's so tragic that you know
in so far as Alison tries to love her
children her children are not easy
people to love and you know Alison
doesn't have a mother herself so I think
she struggles with motherhood lacking a
mother herself like her actor Olivia
Cook has talked about that
so yeah really sad
um Eric says why are some dragons named
cool Valyrian stuff like vegar and
maraxis and valerion but some are named
crap like dreamfire well you've got to
remember that like these dragons bond
with riders who are children and of
course children have silly names for
Dragons because they're children
um I think it's not surprising I mean
it's like the um it's like the Starks
with with naming their direwolves and
like three-year-old rickon names his
direwolf Shaggy Dog because he's a dog
who's Shaggy it's silly but it's so
adorable
um so yeah like of course some of the
targaryens give the dragons names that
are not super badass dream fire I think
dream fire is very appropriate for
Helena because Helena has Dragon dreams
so she names her Dragon after dreams and
fire seems very logical to me
um whereas yeah some of the other dragon
names are like the names of Valyrian
gods and like Valyrian language and
stuff so um yeah that's cool
um thank you ghost thank you old school
I'm I'm gonna avoid repeating
anything that I've already said
thank you for brace and Walker and
Sebastian thank you Cole The Song of Ice
and Fire isn't known
nobody bringing up that viserys may have
meant aegon the Conqueror yeah look I
mean the only person in the room when
viserys was dying was Alison and so
Allison is the only person who heard
viserys's wording about the prince that
was promised in aegon and she thought he
meant her son aegon when he actually
meant aegon the Conqueror
um
so no one else can say oh maybe he meant
aegon the Conqueror because they don't
know that that is how viserys was
talking I mean the other greens don't
care the other greens don't care that
viserys viserys's dying wish was for
aegon to be king because I'll because
they were going to do it anyway like
Allison is kind of the only person who
cares that viserys wanted aegon to be on
the throne so it's not even super
relevant to anyone except Alison you
know
um and I think that that's you know
that's just that's how the
misunderstanding happened it is kind of
silly the misunderstanding being so
consequential but I guess such things
happened in real life
um thank you op and floats who says why
are people following orders from Alison
she derived her power from being the
queen and she's no longer the queen yeah
I mean sometimes the exact hierarchy of
power is not super clear and like with
her ordering people around I mean she
was ordering Kristen around and
Kristen's loyalty is to Alison more than
to anyone else so you know sometimes
what the exact you know command
structure is meant to be on paper is not
how it actually is in practice just like
in the real world sometimes actual
relationships matter more so I'm not
shocked that Kristen is listening to
Alison
and you know it's it's like the sort of
you know it was similar when viserys was
alive
um
uh thank you Liam who says that viserys
is stillborn son was actually Tyrion
traveling through time to stop Daenerys
Jack says was the building burned in
flea bottom an attack targeted at
mazaria yes that was Lara's trying to
kill mazaria with his fireflies
Keegan says that Allison's Shenanigans
are going to cause my wife to throw a
shoe through my TV eventually
Benjamin says mushroom would be so funny
in the show we did get to see mushroom
briefly at Rainier's wedding
uh according to the behind the scenes
stuff this fella is mushroom but yeah he
does have a bigger role in um the books
mushroom is the Court Jester and he
entertains viserys and others in the
family and it's mushroom who claims that
Allison poisoned viserys although
mushroom wasn't in King's Landing at the
time he was on Dragonstone so mushroom
is full of [ __ ] he does make stuff up
but he also is correct some of the time
so that's the whole thing thank you Luke
and Emily
um
and I think we've got to wrap up this
live stream
because I've been talking for three
hours
um I apologize for any super chats that
I missed
um it's been three hours thank you for
your support though and thank you for
watching we're gonna have a very brief
look at the on the next episode preview
trailer so let's do that so if you don't
want to see that on the next episode
preview trailer uh you may wish to avert
your gaze
so uh we see melis we see rainis on
melis I think it is flying to
Dragonstone to say hey rhaenyra the
greens are taking the throne and Otto
wants to kill you
um I wonder if Raines is also going to
tell rhaenyra that like hey by the way
like Alison doesn't want to kill you
Allison is trying to be more like
peaceful so maybe like oppose Otto but
don't oppose Alison that seems like an
important detail that I hope I hope
rhaenys relays to to rhaenyra and again
I I'm really enjoying rainisa's armor I
I love to see some dragon riders in
armor Good Times
um yeah and rainis is telling rhaenyra
that out that that Otto wants to kill
her children
um so this is very real and threatening
and very scary terrain era
we see uh dark sister the Valyrian steel
sword of Daemon is what is ducks is
Doc's sister just leaning against a
table or is it like in a corpse right
now now it's shaved whenever daemon's
around you've got to worry if he's
killing someone
um Daemon is saying don't submit to the
high Towers because you know Alison was
talking about offering a peace offer to
Rainier so maybe Rainier is considering
peace peace peace might save some lives
uh but she's worried about her kids and
she would like the throne and you know
rainy era has a sacred responsibility of
the prophecy handed down by viserys and
you know the alternative to rhaenyra is
aegon who is terrible so there's a lot
of big issues to Grapple with here
um amond is taking off his eye patch
we're gonna get to see what's under
amon's eye patch what does he keep in
there is it a sapphire is it an emerald
is it some snacks can't wait to find out
uh we see the painted table it looks
like rhaenyra has summoned some friends
and allies we see Jace and Luke and is
that that's a kingsguard that's a
kingsguard
um there are a couple of kingsguard
members who we haven't met yet and we
also know that Eric seems to be heading
Rainier's way and Harold we don't know
where Harold is so the kingsguard could
be important because the King's Guard as
well as being good Warriors are also
symbols of political legitimacy and it
is a problem for Rainier that aegon has
aegon's sword aegon's Crown aegon's
dagger he's he has King's Landing like
aegon has a lot of symbols that make him
look like the legitimate King so having
some Kings guard uh is important
um
the painted table is looking very fancy
have they like
poured some molten gold into the
indentations in the map have they
painted the gold in there is that wax is
that I don't know that looks very cool
on the painted table but yeah again this
is like the table made by aegon the
Conqueror before his Conquest
yeah it looks like they've like poured
some like stuff into the table that
looks super cool I like it
um so yeah yeah every man standing
around the painted table is urging her
for war so there's there's definitely
like a gender thing that they're playing
with that all these bloody ambitious men
are trying to start wars while the women
are trying to protect their families
um lay Siege to the red keep says this
fella
and there's maesta gerardus so yeah I
think some people are going to say like
YOLO in there with the dragons right now
people preparing for war and what will
rhaenyra do send us say the children so
so these guys are Dragon Riders Baylor
is a Dragon Rider with Moon Dancer Jace
is a Dragon Rider with Vermax Luke is a
Dragon Rider with arax Rayna does not
have a dragon
she's the odd one out so I wonder how
Rainer can contribute but the kids are
eager to join in like you know just like
at dinner the kids are the most eager
for violence you know getting into
fisticuffs with aemond and aegon so I
wonder how they will be involved uh
we've got someone running up to a dragon
it looks like Luke or Jace running on to
mount their dragon I hope that goes well
for them there's Vega at a castle what
Castle is that I'm not I I don't want to
spoil it we're going to talk about all
about it next week but that's Vega and
it looks like there is a very exciting
confrontation going on there and we see
that Eric Cargill has brought viserys
and jeheris's Crown to rhaenyra so
that's another useful symbol of
legitimacy and maybe this is the crown
that rhaenyra might wear while aegon
wears the crown of aegon the Conqueror
um so we've got Jace writing arax it
looks like or Luke writing yeah Luke
writing arax
through a storm I hope that ends well
for him
um a power that has not been seen your
cause holds a power that has not been
seen since the days of old valyria
um are they talking about what are they
talking about a power that has not been
seen since the days of old valyria are
they talking about like blood magic are
they talking about Vega are they talking
about prophecy what do you guys think
that means in the chat a power that has
not been seen since the days of old
valyria and who's saying it
curious curious and then we get a
dragon's eye
with someone reaching towards the dragon
reflected in the eye
Daemon is singing in High Valyrian maybe
he's um quoting some dragons trying to
get a dragon's loyalty which dragon is
that could that be the cannibal oh
because there are there are some wild
dragons on Dragonstone so I wonder if
Daemon is trying to recruit some more
dragons for their cause maybe Raina is
finally gonna get a dragon
yeah my God that is a big dragon I I
hope that's accountable the cannibal is
like this wild scary dragon that lives
on Dragonstone that may play a role in
the story uh oh my God we got Otto
delivering some peace terms that's cool
it echoes the um confrontation in like
episode two
so hey maybe there's Hope For Peace guys
a summit on Dragonstone will solve
everything and that looks like Vega
all right um that was the preview
Verma Thor yeah yeah maybe it's vermouth
or Silver Wing
yeah Verma Thor might be more likely
than cannibal you guys are probably
right
a dragon horn oh that's an interesting
idea chrysal yeah maybe the power that
has not been seen since old valyria is a
dragon horn because the dragon Horn uh
valyria apparently had Dragon horns that
could control dragons
because the valyrians were more
um
more advanced in their control over the
dragons
all right
um have a quick look at a couple more
Super chats uh do you think Missouri
will take on Laris in the shadows yeah I
think that mazario will be cross with
larus for trying to burn her to death
and it would be really cool to see like
a spymaster versus spy Master you know
struggle in the shadows just like
Littlefinger and Varys were on their own
level you know doing their own fight in
Game of Thrones
when the doors were being shot with
those Lannisters uh yeah there were some
like guards in red outfits I think they
were just like Targaryen guards I don't
think they were Lannisters
do you prefer Hot D or got season one oh
it's it's so different I mean Hot D
definitely benefits from like a bigger
budget more lavish production and I
think they've used that well
um I think both hot day and Game of
Thrones are good like adaptations of the
source material like they both stay
mostly faithful but they make some
pretty smart changes
um
aegon's Throne looks Persian inspired
yeah I I don't think that was his like
Throne per se like I think his throne is
the iron throne but yeah that that seat
looked interesting they talked about
like a Byzantine influence for some of
the design some of the outfits and stuff
um Kristen all women are Queens coal
yeah well Kristen's not a big fan of
Queen raniera however
um
yeah okay we've got to end this thank
you so much for watching
um and we'll see you next time we're
going to make an explained video uh to
explore this episode in a scripted
proper edited video you can listen to
these live streams in a podcast feed if
you would like there is a link in the
description to the alt shift X podcast
uh you can also listen to alt shift x
videos as an audio podcast feed and so
you can also check that out in the
description
you can support on patreon if you would
like you can buy merchandise if you
would like you can buy an ALT shift X
t-shirt you can buy an ALT shift X pin
you can buy an ALT shift X pin and put
it in an ALT shift X t-shirt think of
the possibilities
um and please like And subscribe
and um if you're looking for other house
of the Dragon content in the meantime
there are lots of other great content
creators that you might like to check
out like Joe magician history of
Westeros radio Westeros the ringiverse
podcast
the Tony Teflon David lightbringer
glidus
present Jacobs
there are lots of wonderful creators
that you can go and check out
uh it's a wonderful Community there's
lots of good people making good stuff
and so you should go support them as
well
okay uh wrapping it up thank you thank
you for the moderation from Schubert you
can go and check out Schubert's Channel
if you would like to do that uh and it
is essential that you do not check out
uh alt schwift X Ultra Dex is a
Despicable YouTube channel that has been
uh ripping off alt shift X for a long
time really just just making a mockery
of alt shift X's Style
some people say that all shift X sounds
like alt shift X I don't know what
they're talking about
um and ALT shift X is getting close to
100 000 subscribers and I'm a bit
worried that if Ultra if x hits well
immediately no 100 000.
I'm a bit worried that if allshift x
hits 100 000 subscribers
um it might encourage shift X to make
more videos and that would be a disaster
for us all
all right thanks guys uh be well see you
in the next one cheers
[Music]